important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare to Freddy
and Jason I rather be Hannibal they be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all to Dramatical I know it's
random but I addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flamable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's sing up in the apartment they
call a department and I get the blame
still I be running collecting and Rain
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
AIM check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm anti love my city but I'm still by
Co I got let's switch
that stop n that was dope keep that keep
that keep that going keep that going n
Go ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoil feel to be your dog they
very loyal but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't heard the boy you you ain't got
to say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being aable and they say I'm better than
money because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be Hannibal they be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all to Dramatical I know it's random
but I addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is that Yoga Fire Flame they they
it's saring up in your apartment they
call it department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting and
range you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when was messaging
people on a check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's switch
that what did you doing Don't Stop N
that was dope keep that keep that keep
that going keep that going n Go ahead
look I guess you can say that I'm very
spoil feel to be your dog they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougar and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but com to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is De Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Saron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the r you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to St regardless
back when you was messaging people on
AIM check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm antisocial love my city but I'm
still by coal I got let's switch that up
what you do stop that was do that keep
that going keep that going go ahead look
I guess you could say that I'm very
spoil to be your dog they very loyal but
I ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to said I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y' to messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating rappers but that's all a part of
me being a accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they can Saron up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest of start
regardless back when was messag people a
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
ano love my city but I'm still by Co I
got's Swit what did you do don't stop
that was dope keep that keep that keep
that going keep that going n Go ahead
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled feeling to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't here the boy you you ain't got
to say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
vultron with a gang of cougers and I'm
going places better tell a uber because
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy krer
that's let's do that again
what's going on real as you can see
we're not we're not present you know we
are taking our break but I spent all
week you know putting together some of
the best moments and some of the worst
of this year when it comes to IOP Xbox
related now obviously there's stuff I
miss man when the video started getting
above 3 hours I started having to cut
some stuff all right you lay off me man
man I hope you guys enjoy it I took a
lot of the moments that you guys said on
Twitter and uh you know hope you guys
have a good week we'll be back on the
7th today's my birthday by the way it's
my birthday uh you know I'm 32 I'm
getting old guys I'm getting old but I
appreciate everyone coming through I
might stream today on my channel I don't
know yet I don't know if I'm willing to
risk it kind of want to play something
and just it just vibe off you guys man I
miss you guys but appreciate everyone
you guys have a good one
[Music]
one this PR call Proclaim both loud and
clear a proclamation of
invitation not on
me I cry the Praises of the
ofal store near the river St Lawrence
with a water St through 1,000
I'mma just chill and watch them and
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young whoop
but then they will mistake me for addict
if I can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cuz if you don't give with that
option you going to be single player
like Sovereign you going to get toss in
the bushes by King David royalty and not
a pretender detrimental to a Elemental
what a avatar to a knee Bender I got to
be me though I know it's my destiny work
the Caro who cares if you fly if you
still a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really be steo you like to
collect stuff and that's cool but I got
bad news even if you really was that
dude King still be the king of the
statues since a ju i' been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
that is cool and it's beautiful we let
you know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday a
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a Lord's
Day
[Music]
oh hot mics and all that uh let's do
some mic checks right quick in the new
year right
quick see some levels can I see some
levels people the most beautiful in
world just like that I get ke is Wilding
right
now all right the way I got up anything
like know I was like you we going get so
we going to move forward from Keith
Murray here you here you it was great
and we are live happy New Year and
welcome to 2023 and welcome back to the
I Lords podcast LLC and the Lords of
gaming.net we are back what's going on
people episode number
286 topic made it right a whole a whole
hour in a whole hour intro yes yes yes
and there will be no poll until the end
of
let's get to the topic all right real
quick suicide came remember for 26
months La Lord bronze the members went
the Lords went up vacation last week and
they only got one job never G never
again you lazy lima beans your lazy lima
beans got Yo they got tree
job 15 job man yes I remember that skit
salute Hollywood rules member for 11
months happy birthday L thank you
brother Happy New Year's Brothers great
job by King last night salute salute so
we all set we ready yes sir all right
adct man this oh we got one more drive
by jail $5 Super Chat we running up
these super chats baby holding usage yo
they holding us hostage they don't can
we start the show yeah let's get to the
show don't y want this top they spinning
the block three bit what's
up we can't now we really got to wait
let me play with your joystick $5 Super
Chat happy New Year I've been back for
two weeks and now ready to
unload un for in 2023
whoa whoa the absolute the master of
innuendo let me play your joysticks back
then we got ra and blade to brother with
ch oh you already read that one thank
you no he made another one just said he
made another one okay PS5 equals remake
station equals pay station equals melt
station all right okay okay on to the
topic on the all right on to the topic
so add I'm going set you up man I mean
set you as far as this topic rubben Xbox
game showcase you know we're hearing
stuff um I don't know which angle you
want to attack this from but um yeah
order of games or showcase itself but
this is your topic bro what do you want
to talk
about um so it does look like there's
highly rumors of a
Xbox event coming out you know even Je
and ran all of them they they pretty
much saying the same things uh so what I
really want to talk about is like what
do you expect from this do you expect
like an inside Xbox or maybe like in EN
heighten one or maybe they'll go towards
the same direction that like the state
of plays and Nintendo directs do uh what
is your guys's opinion on that and I
actually want to start with King on this
one the king uh what would you like k
for the Xbox game showcase
2023 potentially road map for game pass
this year oh you going to like the poll
question
[Music]
continue you know everything comes out
in Game Pass so I just want the road map
I don't I'm not one of those individual
I just look at everything logically
logically whatever they showing is going
to be in Game Pass first party titles
stuff like that um anybody just wants to
know what's going to what's their plans
are you have to look at what's going to
happen with um uh the ABK deal which I
don't care about at this point no more
until it's either yay or nay and you
know what to do it's like it's like a
relationship where you just keep saying
oh we going to break up or we going to
be together we going to break up we
gonna be just somebody make up their
mind so this can happen already so we
can know exactly what we going to do and
who else we going to date and what else
we going to buy that's about it CU if it
don't happen then they G to go spend
their money elsewhere if it does happen
then they spent their money where they
were supposed to spend it that's it just
we want to know what's going to happen
with the AB KD but that's later on
whatever's in Game Pass Starfield
redfall um we know it's RPG heavy to be
honest over there I want to know what uh
first person over the shoulders uh third
person over the shoulder story narrative
driven game we don't know that's in the
cut being made that's going to release
that's it I just want to take away
whatever Sony does well and just put it
over here because we know they don't do
RPGs well so we already know Xbox got
that on lot we know they don't do first
person multiplayer Shooters so we know
Xbox got that on lot all they do well is
uh third person story driven story games
so take that from them so they don't do
anything well no more and we just
control the whole board I like what Xbox
have that means Sony can't do it well
anymore well they can do it well but
they do it kind of boring so I just want
you know their type of formula just with
more action okay you know that's it and
those get 90 metritic score
here we go that's the same 90 people
buying
it fair enough I mean I guess my
follow-up question for K would just be
like I know you're you're big on
presentation format so my my followup
for you was just like how would how do
you want this show presented cuz um you
know whether it be inside Xbox format
personalities whether it be Nintendo
Direct style like like all even State
Nintendo Direct style I think Nintendo
Direct and Sony uh jumped on that same
bag bandwagon with the Sony state of
play mhm they copy what's successful I
think Nintendo's formula when they
started that Treehouse stuff was great
so I I really want them to follow the
Nintendo's formula show the game a
little light talking in the
background very small developer segment
you just see their face you hear them
talk about their game a little bit while
the game was playing and go on to the
next game do not do the whole popping
circumstance I don't want to see a
coffee table with different color M&M's
I don't want you making dope no I I
don't I don't want to see that okay okay
if if it's this presentation get to the
games because you gave us none last year
so get to the games I don't want to hear
none of your your spin doctor crap I
don't want to hear you trying to make
nobody the next icon in the industry
just do your job show the games you've
been working on save all that for E3 I
don't want to see no faces I don't want
to see Phil face I see you want to see
the do no I don't I don't because at
this point in time I just want to see
games I feel that I agree I agree at
this point um you know the only Ty only
one person I want to see f is is he's
got like a huge announcement that's all
like you know if he comes out there and
I guess I can understand if he if he's
like leading the show like he's opening
it up with it that's fine but it's like
don't come out there and talk about Game
Pass numbers don't come out there and
talk about no numbers I don't want to
see no numbers on that board I don't
want to see how many Xbox how how many
bugs are grounded with squished that no
I I I want to see games games and games
and I think that at this point you got
to show up or just stay home shut up
this is stay home oh don't even come
outside yeah well just like you did with
don't come out until you do don't come
out until you here's the thing like last
year was was I wouldn't say it was like
a horrible year but if you were just on
Xbox it was a rough year and it's just
like you got to make up for that man you
got you got to show that Starfield um
you know I honestly feel like inside
Xbox is okay they just they need to
restructure it to where the interviews
is at the end of it you know they come
out they they they go over what's going
on they show gameplay and they say if
you want to see more in-depth interviews
M we're going to talk about that after
the showcase on YouTube after the uh
entirety of the Showcase we need to see
release dates on all these games we need
release dates yeah
everything so they can't they can't end
the trailer is I'm not feeling if you
telling me if you telling me everything
from January to June right I want
everything from January to June with a
date with a date not not only for part
quarter no no
I B ba I mean I listen I know things
could move around right in those spaces
right I'm an answer I'm an answer for I
don't even want to see a month I want to
see a date with the month like I don't
want to see no
month we can't even say June no no June
June 18th June 16th June 15th I don't
care bro I mean if you this is the home
stretch for every game that's supposed
to be coming out in that in that first
half of the year it really is the home
stretch so if you have you don't know
when then how many of these games coming
in super hot okay I got questions for
y'all I got question and that's just
worrisome considering a lot of these
games have already been delayed multiple
times so that's my thing it's like if
you still coming in super hot then again
why even bother saying this is coming
out the first half of the year if you're
not a you can't put a date on it in
January in fairness we all agreed 2020
three is stupid stacked oh it's stacked
and we're talking not only Xbox first
party we're talking about third party
Partners we're talking about Diablo
right maybe in the June we're talking
about we just talked about switch coming
in hot Zelda tears of the Kingdom big
link
off big link outside and we know what
big link do so you put your release date
next to somebody fine but that they
already they already set themselves up
by saying hey this is all coming out
before June end of June no here's the
thing regardless how that goes everyone
else is dealing with the same thing too
and they're not mising they're Show
release dates they're showing release of
the Kingdom have a release date yes they
got the kingdom has a release date do
they have a date it says may something
hold on a second do they have a month or
they have a date that's my question
because my thing is I think there's a
lot of I'm not challenging I'm just
saying may my fault I
apologize so everything got dates but
them so my I apologize my question is
now that you know that right now that
now that I know that as far as uh Zelda
and stuff like that and then the Diablo
like what about strategic placement the
only thing I run away from is link
that's the only thing I run away fromo
we move we we can't the only thing I run
away from is link that's it yeah and
it's like there's no strategic placement
when it's already there it's already
installed it's already it's already a
street oh no don't do that do yes putar
fill up against here we go the reason
why I'm saying that is Nintendo guys is
gon to buy a link regardless it don't
matter what's going to happen it's like
you can't run from something that's
inevitable right you can just only
measure yourself up against greatness so
yeah but you you
can't I was G to say you can't run from
something inevitable you can you can
wait for it to leave the
room
Horizon would like to that's enter the
chat that's see you talking about a
whack game versus a good game um what
what what I'm saying here is my heart
don't pump Kool-Aid like I'm I'm I'm not
you know I'm not scared dudes like a lot
of what I hear is a lot of fearing dud
voice run away from link stay away from
I told y'all before if you sure about
your date Step On His date put your 10
toes down what the
deal regardless to what I'm buying link
anyway but I got game pass so my drink
gonna be pre-installing while I'm at the
store buying link and and is and what's
going to dictate me playing what is
who's better for the love God xbo don't
listen to this so listen for the love of
God listen to me because if you strong
about what your belief is you go in
there and you make a person make a
choice you go there you go in the store
visually you put your game up them
visually visuals that's real nice that's
real nice and he said that's cute and
all but in in
practice people gonna run away all right
so so this what I'm telling you s this
is what I'm telling you yeah you buying
link regardless that is true right you
playing Starfield
regardless it's just GNA B down I say
but this is what I'm saying you in game
pass5 up to $70 is this is the fight
here okay okay your joint got to sell
our joint got to
pre-install so $15 is the barrier is
lower go in there barri is lower this is
the first the the IP I got gotta break
protocol my man is in here shout out to
R th9 he said redfall is red on May 2nd
so the idea of Starfield releasing the
week after is absurd k i here my thing
here's my thing do you got that in
writing hold hold do like that I'm talk
I'm not talking rumors so I'm I'm I'm
not gonna do that I'm not gonna allow
you to jump in here and say we don't no
we
know is a fight Day red red if you want
to come in just tell him yeah he get me
on his
show
oh you on that I feel you on that boy
Xbox plus no let me let me let me cuz he
wants throw his bars in yeah yeah get
get your bars back we know the 12 that
if he stuff that you just said that's a
Maybe Might or could be right sound like
somebody scared that's all I'm saying
give us a date like adct said okay
here's the issue I have with that
releasing on Zelda thing let's go how
are we gonna hold them accountable for
releasing on their own IP of Forza and
Halo but we're trying to say he should
release on on Zelda like mean like it's
the thing like when Forza came out and
we was like yo give it time to breathe
we're sitting there telling them Yo give
it on your own IP time to breathe but on
Z no drop that on Zelda why you like a B
drop that when they drop drop that on Z
see this is the thing this is what I'm
trying to say go ahead this is when your
heart pump cooler you hear stuff like
that like you know scary dude talk that
scary dude talk Bigg line your heart
pump like $7 start looking at it from a
logical standpoint okay I'm not I'm not
looking at I know you're not see that's
the problem because because Zelda defies
logic sometimes
bro hold
hold so are you saying just to clarify
yeah that Zelda and Starfield coming out
the same day would not affect Starfield
no you bu you bu you why n you
out okay let me tell you why it's Not
Gon to Zelda is going to do the numbers
that Zelda is going to do regardless
it's not one person that's sitting here
saying
if if Starfield come out I don't know if
I'm gonna buy starfields right but okay
but if the metric if the metric is
engagement the who's gonna be engaging
that's the thing like if you have
everybody that got Game Pass that's fine
but how many people that have Game Pass
are also getting
Zelda talking tax season
month oh that's the factor everybody got
their tax check about the month of the
ballers all right all all right so hold
hold these dudes is walking in the store
saying give me both wa Kid K go then I
go let me address it okay because here's
here's my thing sound too as a
PlayStation fan oh God and the fan boy
you know what a even a PlayStation conv
the same day release that the same day
because you know what over here in the
PlayStation we want Starfield to come
out the same day as Zelda that sounds
like a
an amazing IDE K you know what I think
you're on to something please for the
love of God Xbox release it the same day
no the best part about the PlayStation
dude is he tried that and he got
mollywop right the reason why uh uh
Horizon got
mollywop they didn't have game pass the
game wasn't released as a sale and as an
engagement item it had one Avenue to get
to the
consumer Zelda has one Avenue to get
you're talking you're talking In
fairness to you you're talking game pass
you also talking in your defense we
haven't it's PC right so PC is also
another factor and the Sal okay what
happened you said call time po time po
time yeah pole time but shout out to the
legendary Jean Park in the chat watch he
said If Zelda I gotta break protocols
this the homie and Starfield come out
next to each other Starfield is going to
get Horizon in my house it's going to
get Horizon in your house
yes not gonna go out and buy it I'm
telling you what I'm doing just just to
clarify King we did say that PlayStation
was stupid for not delaying uh Elden
ring not Elden ring Horizon Z Dawn no
zero Dawn you so what's the differ hold
up what's the difference tell now
what's the difference is you're Point
you're doing point of sale versus point
of sale okay if Microsoft didn't have
other avenues to get you Starfield then
I would tell you move the date they have
complete
diff 30 million you got a 30 million
head start on whatever uh uh um Zelda is
selling you have a 30 million Head Start
as far as Nintendo us bases
you're looking at it from z z runs over
Mario think about that you're looking at
it from you're looking at it from a
sales Point standpoint I'm looking at it
from both of these are massive games and
we can only play one right you can only
play one no but but King in addict's
defense you're acting like everyone got
CH Chilla disposable income to just do
both at the same time or make a decision
that's that's it I have faith in the 30
million strongness ins our Game Pass
okay going to download it I have Fai
that PC dudes that don't got a switch
that's going to download it and buy it I
have faith in the fact of the product
what I'm trying to tell you is stop
letting your heart pump cool no it's not
no pumping you you disrespected what
Zelda do like let me get my bar off now
you your ego and chillness is so big
that you acted like Zelda has not been
dominating dudes outside for a minute we
just we have two like it's not about
running it's about being smart like at
the end of the day not only do you have
the zelder factor right you got the fact
that we got Diablo close five and then
we foret hold on we foret one other
thing that in your defense I'm trying to
help you no you got you got you see you
been too arrogant but you got your own
redf that you got to decide where
redfall plays and all it you can't
cannibalize redfall you got to let them
bre too so it it it's it's a Strate all
I'm saying is strategic placement I know
you call it scared but I'm calling it
strategic plac you have to allow this
game to breathe your other first party
game to breathe your third party
Partners game to breath and big link is
coming home tears of the he got a te got
a body down all right check this check
this right check it check it let's say
red fall come out in February okay Xbox
news@ xbox.com Xbox wire Xbox and
Bethesda to present the Developers
direct live stream on January 25th and
it's called obviously the developer
direct and presented by the game
creators themselves from Studios such as
arcade Austin Mojang Studios turn 10
studios zamax online the developer
direct will focus on big features
extended gameplay showcases and latest
info for Xbox games launching in the
next few months including the Elder
Scrolls Online Forza Motorsport
Minecraft Legends and redfall and they
said to dedicate the proper amount of
time for a deep dive into but Des game
Studio Starfield a standalone show is in
the works and then to follow up with uh
Lorden greeny Aaron Greenberg on Twitter
he said that and since many folks have
asked our show is tracking 43 minutes
long so um yeah he says outlining this
announcement our goal has been to be as
transparent as possible on what the devs
and teams and games expect to see in the
show so this has hit the interwebs uh
adct this is your topic how you want to
approach it man
I just want the general you know
impression of the Lords and Lord Jean
you know I I still I I'm I'm okay with
them coming out and saying like look
don't expect Starfield here I understand
the decision behind it I understand it's
a big game but at the same
time I don't agree with not having here
in any way shape or form you can easily
show this game in some way if it's a new
trailer some kind of you know maybe
minute trailer with uh IID prefer a
release date and then it's like you know
if you want to see more in-depth on this
game we got an event for you and then
they show the release state to that
event uh it's just I just feel
like it really makes me think this
game's getting push back to late 2023
because it's just like I don't
understand why you're bringing this to
the to the front and these games are
supposed to come out in the next five
months oo
are you implying that the the
development I mean the marketing cycle
might not be time enough if it's coming
what are we what are we doing an what
what you say unless I don't think we're
going to get
the the um the actual event for
Starfield next month because at that
point I maybe it's just a time restraint
or anything like that but it's just like
maybe we'll get like the beginning of
March okay I I I don't know cuz like
it's just if it's just weird it's like
you heard the same thing right
Jean I you try to make him an NBA dude I
see what you
doing it's just this is your biggest
game this year this is the game
everyone's asking for this is the game
that people realistically expected at
the Video Game Awards and this is the
only game you're not showing like and
like cool I get it it's a big game you
want to give it enough time to really
unwind unwrap Starfield but you could
easily do that and still have Starfield
at this event I'm not giving them that
excuse you could easily have Starfield
at this this event because it's coming
out this six
months
allegedly and you could easily still
look but we're gonna have a breakdown
next month the month after that but
here's what you needed to know here's
when it's coming out and if you want to
see more information on this game you
can watch that event when that
just to be clear before we open it up to
Jean yo they stupid 108 is he said adct
world is in full effect I heard that in
a while but it fair this to my man it f
is to my man so your concern is because
they even though they set expectation by
telling that it's not going to be at
this vet you're concerned that it not
being at this vet that something is up
as far as the release no nothing even in
that it's like look like people expected
this at the Video Game Awards and when
we didn't see it at the Video Game
Awards we were told it's soon now we get
this event that's soon and it's still
not at the soon event that we were
teased a month ago that there had more
information they didn't say Starfield
was going to be there but they said but
they said we will show you more and
everyone is looking for Starfield sure
people are excited about red ball sure
people excited about about Minecraft
Legends but everyone is looking for
Starfield and they came out there and
they said we will have more information
on you guys shortly and then when we get
more information oh but we gotta wait
longer for that one like no like it
would be different this game was coming
out in November and we knew it was
coming out in November okay you know you
got plenty of time but you didn't mean
to tell me this game's supposed to come
out in five months and we and at the end
of this month we're having an event and
we're still not seeing this game so they
like a month Mar trouble in Paradise
something wrong are they gonna have like
a month of marketing before the game
comes out the greatest marketing
ever look I mean adus f okay let's open
it up first let start with je Lord Jean
um I'm going back to my
grapes yo you f he got his red I'm GNA
go back to eat after I ran it um so my
question is little G is first of all
about to develop a direct announcement
you know what are your thoughts on that
and then obviously the second part what
adct alluded to about Starfield having
its own
show uh I think I'm kind of like with
your with your boy Maddie here where
it's like it's interesting to see how
they missed the opportunity for game
awards because Maddie said and I also
agree with saying that they had a missed
opportunity to hit the The Wider gaming
audience uh because like you know again
and and we saw we saw Jeff key come up
with the numbers you know like BL like
mind-blowing like audience numbers that
was that's a captive audience that that
Xbox missed and like it's it's
surprising that with even within the
last two months they couldn't even show
up for that yeah you know but but but
they could show up for for this later on
like something's going on you know um
and yeah it's disappointing that
Starfield is is still being pushed off
you know and and and Xbox themselves set
that expectation back in June back in
June by saying like like you know these
are going to be winning the year we
didn't ask for that we didn't ask point
the TW I agree I didn't like the 12mth
format I'm sorry no no no no I'm with
you that that that nobody really asked
for that and like you know like like and
and I appreciate like the the the intent
of it you know because like you know
nobody appreciated seeing Fable like or
like as a Nintendo fan nobody
appreciated seeing Metro Prime 4 like
four or five years ago we still got
nothing on that too yeah tell the truth
and Shane the devil sir tell the truth
Shan the devil microsof heal a different
state let me address the chat real quick
first off thinker sitting there saying
you're mad annoying hold that timeout
you can be in
timeout saying
you no second off saying addict I want
to get I want them to get more time in
what way shape or form do you think
doing one cannot do the other you could
easily do both do you think that because
that one trailer is at a show everyone
is not working on Starfield stop it man
I'm going back to my grave continue
continue G we we got the ran off
again uh yeah I don't know I I I I don't
know what what what Xbox can do to to to
Market it though I'm not you know I have
no experience in marketing video games
worldwide uh but like man like just to
to what that commenter said it would be
Nic to have that kind of energy because
you know when when I do think about it I
you like last last week you guys said
that this is the biggest exclusive for
Xbox is the first Halo and I was like
well maybe gears but then when you
really think about it not really gears
uh it it it really is it really goes
back to Halo one I
think I think that is true because this
is this is this is for game pass this is
the argument for game this is the
argument for Game Pass dude this is this
is the argument for Xbox's like business
fut you know and and Starfield is a
centerpiece of that argument yes you
know so it needs to it needs to get out
there it needs to knock you know yeah it
needs to get out game pass it needs to
be clean it needs to be a clean game it
can't it can't be like what bedda used
to be before you
know and you know and it's it's got to
be 1080 it's got to be 60 frames at
least at least at least at 1080p at
least at 1080p you know question if if
it is if there is no performance
mode I wouldn't care I'd be fine with it
because because because I one of the few
people who look look I grew up on Xbox
360 like we were playing games like 20
20 frames per second back the day you
know so it's like I'm I'm okay with that
like like like I'm I'm I'm I'm
acclimated to all that you know uh 60
frames I'm on PC but but yeah you're on
PC and we are never going to hear the
end of it if it isn't 60 frames we're
never going to hear the end of it
everyone's gonna be G to be complaining
about it you know you know the Sony
Fanboys aren't ever going to let up on
it they're gonna be relentless mean they
can't really be upset because a lot of
their games is 30 frames per second
anyways I
can't I think my mindset is
like the fact that it's been so extra
with Microsoft about performance modes
that's an L if their Flagship game for
this year doesn't have a performance
mode yeah we'll be interesting a lot of
systems we'll see what happen no but I I
hear you I hear you J in reference to
you know what you said in you know as
far as setting the expectation with the
game awards right and and being the fact
that they utilized that platform before
to Showcase things so them not there but
to your point I think you know having
the making this announcement I guess my
question to you is do you think they set
the proper expectation with announcing
the developer direct and saying now hey
look St we're going to dedicate its own
show do you think that was the right
approach with that information put out I
think if they really don't have the
information for Starfield already then
they got to do that they had to do that
you know it was you know but the way I
see it is damage control ahead of ahead
of it you know that's what it is you
know okay yeah because they had to do
that yeah for me it is objectively
damage control like like preemptive
damage control that sucks again imag
wait imagine if we waited for that Jean
and Starfield wasn't there and they
didn't say wasn't going to be oh I was
yeah that was those my boss so I was
literally going to say yeah they would
have been held to pay if they did that
for sure like like like I would write at
the capital I would go I go you you go
storm the Xbox
offices it'll be
Insurrection orza because because PDA is
right up the
street we try get G locked up man I'm
I'm okay with it not being there because
they are going to give me such a big
deep dive but it's like at the same time
it's like dude like you guys when that
came out and jumped the gun and said 12
months and then like I'm sitting here
looking at the at the calendar and it's
just like yo it don't look like this is
12 months even though this could easily
come out in 12 months but it doesn't
it's just I wish they never would have
said that 12 months
thing I wouldn't be surprised if it
comes out later a lot like a lot of
Kool-Aid well here's the thing though I
said I wouldn't even mind if Starfield
got pushed back off that June day I
don't it's just my my thing is if it got
I just don't want it if they do another
12mon thing this year I don't want them
showing a game that was supposed to be
in the 12 month last year no no let me
tell you something let me tell you
something and I'mma keep it a 100 I'm
I'mma call Jean if they missed this 12
months Jean going to go down there we
going ra h
the thing they they they gave they
pigeon hold themselves is yeah they did
they told them they listen I'm let's be
anyway this is this is a Todd Howard bgs
open world game in no world in no world
it it would
be what you what are you implying
scenario there's no scenario it be it
would be wishful thinking be careful to
think that this
game comes out in any state other than
somewhat
broken it is and and and it all depends
on whether it's playfully broken like oh
look at this astronaut with boobs coming
out of his head cool fny or or if
sh violet yeah there you go or is it
damn my every time I try to boot the
game up it it crashes the whole whole
house turns off you know the problem the
problem with this game is most most
Bethesda Games come out they're buggy at
the beginning until they get that first
couple patches done right but the fun
factor is s is far surpassed the
annoyance Factor
right even even though they didn't make
Fallout 76 sister Studio made that game
so they had to take the L for that they
have to there was nothing to do really
in that game so you only dealt with the
issue right so this is the thing right
to me looking back on it James said
something about how they have to be a
different Bethesda I think the one thing
that they I think they wish they would
have done is to not even acknowledge the
exist existence of this game until until
six months but they that they were 100%
sure internally this game was ready come
out you pull the Fallout 4 you don't
acknowledge the existence of the game I
don't even care if it is a new IP people
going to be excited about it no matter
what it's a new bgs game now to addict's
point they had the stumble of oh we have
to answer for 76 right we have to answer
for 76 so the next thing we come out we
have to talk about it because hey we
have to make sure people are confident
in what we're bringing to the table we
did that to ourselves my thing is if
look at all the conversations we're
having it better be 60 it it can't if it
if it this this hypothetical window that
they created for themselves which is
unnecessary rake
right we're all arguing about how much
of vanill it is if it goes past the 30th
of June or whatever does what happens if
they never said anything about this and
then at E3 they're like you'll be
playing the the next BDS game in
November okay King King why did they
come out and you know like you being T
behind closed doors we can have this out
hold up hold up yeah yeah okay so so NDA
dude you're being told you're being told
yo it's up to you King do I release this
in May right now 30 frames to drive
release it in July 60
frames you missed that date I'm coming
for your forehead that's it but again
when I say
when you you going get the full me pause
after that's why when I said and hold
when I say they P that's exactly what I
mean you put yourself in a position to
fail the consumer unnecessarily right in
a lot in so many ways to me I'm G be
honest I don't I like I like being
surprised by stuff by games I like being
coming coming into a year and be like I
don't know what's going to come out we
have IDE like the only person on the
panel that I'll find some juicy stuff
out man stuff that no one else I was
like don't tell me don't tell me don't
tell me I I don't want to know I I love
the secrecy around games because it
makes so when we when we do
reactions sols is genuine like didn't
know nothing about I know nothing I know
nothing and that's why my track
record I've had people literally I've
had people literally message me an
entire show right before the show before
like it's it's ridiculous like and I
would be I would curse that person out
they did that to me you know how it is
like when you open a message and you
start reading before you realize what
you're reading it's too late like so so
my thing my whole thing is this I I like
I like the I like the fact that they're
saying hey we're gonna come out we're
gonna give you deep Dives in these games
all right I do think 40 minutes without
star good too 40 minutes without starfi
don't forget the extra three 43 so it it
really is and then you have then you
have the eldest girls online uh extended
thing right after right which is which
is interesting I feel like they should
have gave that to the Video Game Awards
like that's probably something they
could have easily put it there and they
it would have got because I think they
should but it does feel like that
whatever the eso stuff is is very
substantial it's substantial yeah they
even having a show after right that
right the extended thing so my thing is
this Starfield Starfield does deserve
its own thing I I don't necessarily
agree that by saying that it's it's it's
coming afterwards it's an indicator that
the game is going to miss that that that
hypothetical window they created for
themselves um because again I just to me
the moment you gave yourself the the
opening to move the game to 2023 it
should have always been 1111
2023 I don't understand why you don't
give yourself enough why I gota wait a
because you want
that it's a game that no matter
what numeric genius now you just told me
that the number they gave you they
better stick
hold hold up hold up hold hold up so I
just want more time you're saying you
they gave you more time when they told
you push it back from when it was
looking ugly it was just one thing that
was I'm tell you this I'm I don't if
it's broken beyond
belief no if it is if it is I want I
don't want to hear the king I don't want
to hear the king I don't want to hear
the king if it's
broken you said that they broken you
said this this is from your mouth this
God how it touches comes out here we go
to know
if God and on God and them you're going
to tell me that if this game got pushed
to 2024 it still wouldn't it still would
and I guarantee you it still be broken
in some way guarantee oh man y get him
out of here I guarantee you I guarantee
you tired of
your yo listen look look no no this is
indictment on all of you dud I
didn't how am I IND
this is not soft talk Sunday y I have I
have ask y yo I'm going tell you right
now but what I don't I don't even
understand what you're defending my I'm
defending soft talk
Sundays supped to
be but yo yo by me saying that it's
going to be broken no matter what I'm
defending them no but CU cuz and your
logic is no matter what he does to it he
going to ship a
broken so if it don't if it ship
tomorrow or ship in November by your
special 11
1123 I agree with 100% yo there's still
aspects of aspects of Skyrim that are
still broken so what you it's still the
greatest selling game of all time it
does not so what I'm saying is though if
they tell you if Todd Howard was like
you know what it's still too broken to
come out in this in this window saying
that to telling you was a go to told you
was calm it down you ain't shipping that
Dam buddy not on my saying I don't want
to hear I don't want to hear complaints
from King that it's it's sub you're not
going to hear no complaint me all you
know why why you know why you're not
going to hear no complaint because this
game is coming out in June so you ain't
gonna hear no complaints from me now
okay I'm sick and tired of you Xbox
dude go no no I think I think it was
Jean's turn I'm sorry Jean's turn he
don't want it ain't Jean don't need to
take this smoke this smoke is definitely
for you Xbox dude that are too soft and
too scared to take it to afraid all
right oh um I want y'all to do uh a I
want to know what's the road map they
gave you a road map they gave you 12
months of road map right so you sitting
there like we don't like the road map
because the road map is not good for us
wait a second you want it this way and
you want it that way they told you that
soft they said give us like four months
right cuz I remember the joint okay NDA
do crap
um you get that information needs some
polishing it's in some polishing phase
right so they gave you longer than four
months and you still complaining it's
gonna come out all right so okay they
said they gonna give you a show addict
literally said I'm sick and tired of you
showing your stuff at the game awards
use your own damn platform Phil went
there sat there and said we ain't
showing you a damn thing and he was all
Natty
he damn thing and Y say why the hell is
Phil sitting there smiling and he ain't
got no game up there he said because I'm
doing my own damn show in January so
January coming and he s you why do
Microsoft have to tell y'all what's
gonna be at the show I'm so sick and
tired of Sony don't Nintendo don't you
just show up and you get what you get
right and and and if they walk off the
show and don't show you God of War y'all
sit there be like maybe next time right
y don't care right but they told you
ahead of time yo don't even come here
looking for Starfield that's on a
separate show later on y'all not happy
with that why ain't they never satisfi
kid that's the problem why ain't at the
show why this broken game that no matter
when they ship it's GNA be broken why it
ain't cuz it's broken and you got to
wait for the other show so y'all can't
have it both ways and I want you to
stand on your chest right have some
Faith Microsoft told you by June by June
June J and we going to get another 12
months of Christmas another 12 months of
good games coming so right now you going
to watch redf cuz they're pushing
redfall right now you going to watch
Minecraft you going to watch Forza you
getting those three games first before
Starfield Starfield is bringing up the
rear like Barry barondes and he's gonna
knock it out the park and he ain't gonna
be broken so stop being afraid and just
sit there this ain't soft talk Sundays
we gonna get this done yo get itan every
time every time somebody put their neck
out first they
die you know what I die so you can live
yeah that's fine that's fine but let's
just remember leonitis walked in walked
into that that little alow with
300 he make it
out the craziest thing is they know
exactly who he is and they know his
story your story will never be told
because you you sitting there you want a
glorious
death tell my go tell my story tell him
how I stood on this and I stand on this
right right now I'm with Phil so the
star have to die or something else you
know you know why you know why they have
to be able to succeed you have to have
faith right I got faith he hasn't proven
me wrong yet who is that he said when
when when Phil told you he's not gonna
ship a broken game if it's not ready he
don't care he did it with
Halo it was millions of marketing
dollars do but he did it with Halo yeah
but you know what it was better than
shipping that broken game in the state
wait a minute this go this flies in the
face of everything you're defending
you're about to say you're about you're
gonna give them the smoke if they don't
meet that June deadline because he said
you know listen listen let's go you
don't tell me you don't tell me here pay
this for this game pass this is gonna be
this this is gonna be that we thought
that Starfield and red FS coming out
this year I'm paying Game Pass I didn't
back up off of that you said 12 months
right so I'm G to sit here with this 12
months that you said I'm living up to my
commitment my commitment is support and
being a consumer live up to your cons
your your commitment on delivering on
your promises like you said right so
your promises like you said is 12 months
right 12 months ain't up I'm not
bothering you Tick Tock buddy Tick Tock
okay because that June come in and you
didn't fly right I don't care if redfall
hit I don't care if Forza hit I don't
care if Minecraft hit if that Starfield
ain't out you are mine
so 12 months I'm here I hope you did too
and what I'm what I'm saying is is I
think if hindsight is 2020 they're like
we we do not we should have never said
anything about this damn game I agree
ever
everever G you sound like you before I
get my bars off I need sound like he was
ready to jump in that's want to make
sure he had any thoughts or he just
listened to us go
crazy but I think I think my biggest
question with Starfield is what kind of
Bethesda game are we going to get you
know because like we we were talking
earlier about how in Oblivion and Skyrim
you can like pick up anything you can
pick up literally like every little
thing like like on the desk right right
I I have a hard time like seeing a game
like that running at 60 frames you know
right so complexities so are are they G
to peel some of that back where it's
like you know like like do you really
need to pick up everything in Starfield
you know I don't know you know like like
what kind what kind of Bethesda game are
we going to get you know because like
God you look at her you know like like
you look Horizon forbidden West and like
that is a gorgeous game that runs at 60
frames per second you know and and like
that kind of It kind of reminds me of
like like a bedz game except that you
can't really just pick up everything
like it's more of it's more of an action
game right so it's like when when I look
at Starfield I'm like okay that this
kind of looks like that kind of game
where you can have conversations and the
conversations and action are are the
centerpiece of it and not so much like
oh am i g to steal this space the space
food you know like like like it's stuff
like that necessary I don't know you
know mhm no I mean it's a good question
right the based on their history and the
scope of their games you know how you
know extensive is it going to be in that
regard and you I'll jump in this is fun
that would just just just to comment on
that if they roll back on that oh the
the Maddie madd's not gonna be happy I
mean the the the dgs faithful if they
roll back on that level of
interaction it's going to be a
conversation all right let me flip it
yeah because because we're still talking
about Fallout 4 and and how they roll
back so many like pieces and everything
too really have dialogue trees much in
that game well the thing that I think
that they start off with a very good
start is no voice protagonist right
because I actually like that where it's
just like me too yeah I can in my mind
this is who I want it to be and when you
kind of pigeon hole into a voice and I
think that was one of the major mistakes
I was you know Ma reason why people
don't receive Fallout 4 as well as three
and then a lot of the to your point Jee
the peeling back of the systems right
and is not as you know in depth as um as
three was but look you know first let's
talk about the direct you know I thought
they did a fantastic job setting the
proper expectation you know for me
personally I feel like you have first of
all Jan is 100% right I was completely
upset that they did not show at the game
awards I think that was a missed
opportunity I've said before at nauseum
they set the expectation by being at the
game awards they showed the series X at
the game awards they showed hellblade at
the game award they showed perfect do at
the at the game awards so they've
they've opened thems up to an audience
that is not familiar with the Xbox brand
and has the most eyes right they didn't
show up in there I thought that was a
mistake now it's course correction they
come out with the Tweet after the game
awards hey we've got something cooking
for you guys soon okay cool now greeny
comes out with the Tweet hey we're going
to have a show develop a direct I like
the name you know what I'm saying I
don't mind it you know what I'm saying
develop a direct developer focus seems
to be less P personality focused which
is one of my issues with inside Xbox
just show me the games from the devs
let's get to it love that um obviously
red fall is going to be big for them I
know people hate on my Minecraft's a
huge game I hate I hate to break it to
y'all but Minecraft is a huge Minecraft
is the biggest game there is the biggest
game going like I I know people that
that's what it is Forza is going to be
there very interested no one's talking a
lot about Forza Forza to me is going to
tell me a lot about this release Cadence
mhm because if we get according to the
German um XBox uh direct developer
direct information on on the German Xbox
site they said release dates so that to
me now you're setting the expectation
for is going to let us know okay where
does that fall the rumors allegedly with
red fall is made right there for to come
before that right where does it fall in
that pocket then you got the Minecraft
Legend and then surprisingly I didn't
expect to see Elder Scrolls all live so
I thought that was interesting and then
you know to the point where we're going
to get a new chapter and then we do know
the zenmax is working on another MMO you
know live service type IP does that get
revealed you know I'm curious but I
think the expectation was right and of
course red fold is huge this is Arcane
this is a huge deal this is Co-op this
is in a different space for them you
know a lot I know some people have
concerns but I'm starting to hear like
you saw like people kind of more lowkey
excited for redf you yeah I got a shout
out M now Maddie I love you man but you
sounded like the old man yelling at the
CL he don't he don't he don't he he's
you can only do immersive Sim in a small
controlled environment
no Far Cry 2 and three uh Zelda breath
of the wild it can be done in arcade
shout out to man I understand this
concern I understand from a person who
loves a studio for specific things and
when you start to see them alter a
little bit yeah but what I tried to say
is the bag and how now they're
critically acclaimed for like death Loop
and all this new stuff there's a whole
new audience and he's holding on it's
like it's like in hip-hop where we just
want people to sound like rock ham all
day you know what I'm saying like I feel
you the guard MC I feel you but yo you
know I would people
like they don't like certain that's what
it is so I get where he at so let's get
to the main event the star situation
very interesting very interest first of
all salute to them because if adct is so
right if they would not have said that
and we showed up to the develop direct
watched a whole 43 minutes of developing
direct and there was next
one bro but
wait there there's no more there would
have been held to pay you know what I'm
saying so salute to them getting in
front of that I love the fact that
Starfield is getting a deep dive you
need to give God Howard the proper top I
want to know about all the systems the
dialogue the factions I want to see the
gun play I want to see some of them um
procedurally generated planets I want to
see a lot of this future Tech that's so
ambitious I want to know so yes give
them their date I love it and I need to
see God Howard come out with the jacket
that's just me anyway I need the brown
leather that in my life that's what I
know it's official it's real anyway back
on point so now the question that is
talk about is is interesting I gotta be
real king last week thought about it
some more and even though the official
page
says first half Starfield
release the only question I have
is where in the hell do you fit it if
it's it first half because here's the
thing all right let's just say may is
what you call it um redfall right
Minecraft Legends got to get a date what
month is that Forza got to get a date
what month is that I think for is out
first you think for is first you think
for think for is probably in February
March so you g to say let's say March
right so then you have that then the
direct for Starfield in March okay so
did say Starfield April like oh when you
say starfi Starfield is in
June I think Starfield you still say the
hold June you think it's June post E3 I
think no I think it's before E3 I think3
so let me explain why I think it's
before E3 break it
down these are the only people that's
still holding tradition right I mean
Nintendo shows up to E3 uh Sony just you
know they figured that they're going to
sell anyway so why waste money uh
singing to the choir right Microsoft is
still trying to gain ground how do you
nullify what anybody does during
E3 put out Starfield do control the
narrative do you hit him with the G
Howard come out on stage and right now
you'll be playing it like doing what
those well what what I think is what we
doing on that on that uh Starfield
direct you get a
date I think he you know you you have to
put the Line in the Sand right you you
give them a date because anytime a
company puts out a date that's a direct
line to whoever right when your G I know
you when when Sony put out the the date
for uh God of War it's like I dare you
put your stuff over
there Nintendo put out breath of the
wild date they said I dare you I know
what you got coming I dare you come
close to this date right so now you up
to that as a company you have to
strategize right you already seen the
first opening Salvo for whoever it is I
think Microsoft can put it that weak
just to gain the Mind share okay it's G
to sell no matter what right but how you
nullify whatever big announcement
somebody else's does is by having actual
product in hand so they have product
that they're playing and you're talking
about something in the future like yeah
we'll get to that but right now though
this is on
this E3 or after E3 I say before E3 to
take away whatever Thunder preemptively
like June like the 4th or 5ifth or
something like that but they call
[Music]
Diablo if you don't own them if you
don't own them right now you can't
cannibalize something at that pace I
think Diablo's going to do what Diablo's
going to do right huge I know but you
can do at probably at the end of the
month probably in the beginning of the
month I don't know how flexible you are
with it if
you top of June like I will say this
there's a big success story uh of a game
coming out and and that that's Last of
Us Last of Us came out 2013 weak of of
the week leading up to E3 see and so
again if if you have that level of game
right then yes because all of a sudden
people like damn okay we seen all this
new hot stuff and that's amazing but we
got this we got this 10 right here
waiting for us and it does something
because Again Last of Us it could have
easily gone gener hype going into the
conferences too yeah for the level of
quality of stuff you're gonna show
because like hey look everybody
questioned us look at this the biggest
game we have coming out we we we hit the
nail on the head we got it done so it
gives people
a reason to be excited for what's coming
right now it could backfire if you try
to do that in the game is a seven then
you know but uh if you hit that last of
us level of hype going into E3 but here
I can see it if if it's what king is
talking about so that means you're gonna
show whole in your shows and everything
on the floor Starfield but but here's
the thing like they literally said
they're going to do a standalone show
right so that means a separate show okay
you talk and then you're going to show
it again at E3 then because no they said
they said that they're going to show it
at that event and the height from
playing it is going to carry into car
into E3 and then release at the M that's
where we going okay I just want to see
what you about no it I think come out E3
before E3 okay so I don't
know how they feel about Diablo that
Diablo though man it's or something like
that like
where can you like strategically place
that with Diablo popping out on the 6th
of June yeah I don't if if if you pop it
out at the beginning then it's just
gonna Diablo might take it Shine away
Diablo's
good they don't get the audio till the
joint
start attic is the club own crazy the
reason it's like that is because I just
got back from the gym and I have a whole
lot of time to do anything yeah his
elbows are
sore on the real though like I have a
bad shoulder and it's been making work
out oh you got to take that joint
support that I use with uh Advanced GG
uh you know get the gummy yo they got no
audio still hard like no audio no audio
oh now they say perfect okay yeah it's
perfect now okay so what you do is take
the advanced GG um joint support take it
you take yeah you got to get your joint
support bro you supp to C it up real
real quickly sir get them gummies bro
yeah I took this one okay
good too yeah and all don't do don't do
don't mess with that guy uhuh we he's
been
debunked oh the liver King
yeah I me liver pills liver pills oh you
eating liver pills yeah yeah that's you
TJ huh yeah all right that's why your
that's why your camera off the effects
of liver pill
J yeah don't be hating on everything in
this stream my dude like Bo yeah they
don't be likeing J
with the Nega
energy you see the
XX wither
he not negative last stream oh yes you
are they the whole comment section let
me know not to bring you back oh yeah
yeah I was like do not bring him he's
bringing the room down we outside nah
budy we going to see all of this
question in the chat question for the
chat do you guys like the format we have
now cuz I'm going to eventually have an
overlay made for us
I said we like the boxes it's
cool say yo adct just just don't m game
works they're going to be here yeah pH
is outside really working unlike other
CEOs it's
outside I'm so mad supped to have a date
that's not good
man game I like that
oh what's
this that's me and you're probably
wondering how I ended up that J Radio
pretty standard his arm is
bionic check this
out music player my chest it's powering
up my new robot arm the redacted game
it's making everything sink up with the
beat that's right oh this a death radio
okay you I like this hard Style yeah
fire like
yep what in the hell am I looking at the
name take down this
company one boss at a
time Yeahs over a little bit of classic
on radio and a little bit of like drag
play okay a platform M it's the people
that make Evil Within yeah see right
there seriously okay
naturally yo Rush that look how Tango
Wii Rush fion projects look like they
making it future
Rockstar I'm Studio head at gaming walks
thank you for all your po over the years
and I'm John Johannes director on highi
R work right
[Applause]
there oh yo you know what it it reminds
me of what was that game that out and
spend all that money on to get what you
talking The Joint that we had first um
Sunset Overdrive yeah that's what I
said so everyone thinks of us out hard
games like even Within spooky games
like but this is clearly something
totally different and if this game
hasn't already leaked fingers crossed we
hope it's a pleasant surprise
BR let's have some fun member 29th glad
to be here with the forat crazy turn
legit doubt this crazy akw in the
building have a great
show support the pxi 2023 so we've been
waiting for this for a long time let's
jump in explain game good be like yo is
it
ours this our sty look clean but do we
own it it said is it
mine my baby no that's not hash just was
Sir but it a bit of a Twist on your
traditional action here your moves and
attacks
help that means all your flashy moves
stylish and devastating third person AC
third person
the ability got a beat beat you are in
total control during combat but
everything you do sinks up like an
awesome music
video That's highi Rush Oh this look
scalebound the better verion play
chai want to be rockar victim of a we
corate experiment that let him sense
rhym entire world hold on let me get on
beat before I beat you
up hold on we beat you to as you can see
the beat moves the world around why he
got to get all be
for me your attacks will automatically
sink to land on the be Rush beat you to
the start
playing however attacking on the beat
leads to combos that end with
countdown simp crash at end a drum Sol
like
this Landing beat hits unleash a combo
finish that adds unique musical FL high
damage
attack fire I go for this kind of fire
this got fire I even go home you this
kind to fire
it's not just what relax
but remind me of those great games we
played on the 360 so long ago yes guy
that did this oh yeah
dream all the way back giving me dream
have a great
show3 my birthday oh yourth happy Bor
day
akw
day I see you
peace
lady say high five rush just won the
direct for her I'm good for the rest of
the show never restrained by the
music whatever you want it's not
about the key here
ising yep very colorful very Nintendo
Yes how long has this been develop
what's see they go to DJ feel like I bet
you this comes out I bet you this comes
out in February by missing the but you
get rewarded
I just some more
more
but it comes out on um Valentine's Day
girl can break
up univ right there cutenes oh that's
cool dangerous obstacles you name it
this is good this is a good way to
demonstrate G ongoing jam session of a
game can we admit that pacing is
phenomenal
this comp who literally a direct 2.0
helps you find version right
now to even more oh we get there later
let's just get this let's just finish a
to
enjoy let's land the play clean first
that's why I can't stand Xbox heads man
CH also gets by with friends what help
for the friend we got I really like how
they're seing everything to the beat
this SL we'
got
Moves In and Out of
combat let me say we got two and four
along with Macon
smashing to switch off yeah I go right
there there my man
brus that's my man the
b b how can you go baby five $2 high
five rough is para rapper the rapper hey
yo I used to like
that I told you the platform now we're
see different
biomes okay they doing something got a
squad now okay I'm feeling the vi taking
down
thees
scale scale y was asking for but good
you'll fight through each department to
take them all on each level with their
own musical spin on the Rock genre yo
and then we have a showdown shout out to
the OverWatch scen mhm
yo a let's get ready to crumble battles
are the whole game on
the 9 in nail Black Keys Prodigy wait
they got real they got real DRS they got
real
AR like nothing we made Tango before got
the bad and we think it's like nothing
you've ever played before
either this feels real 90 Metacritic for
amazingly satisfying
sir um you guys there's a surprise I'm
not going to spoil about this game but
enjoy
mhm pretty Rockstar move chai high five
Rush stealing the show right now
stealing the
show steal it way morej did his thing
the legend he said and it's out right
now on your
Xbox oh man don't do this to his kid he
said see you later
right
now said you could pet that cat what the
other real surprise what real
surprise it's your game John let's go
Prophet King not only were super psyched
for you to play this we're happy to tell
you that you can play high tonight Dro
Down's
go he said I know there a lot of people
in the world s for spoking
game we hope you go get in your game
pass all right I'm the stream
guys all right guys it's been
real it's been real about to go
available I need to download yo how many
years have we' been saying they need to
drop a game like it's right
now oh surprise somebody been listening
mind if I join all right I need to When
does the when does Game Pass refresh
every day I'm going tell you right now
we need to give legend of the year every
year this
2023 I want to see Twitter full of time
the timeline full of high Rush this is
well you know those guys don't play
games Twitter is a game it's crazy they
revealed a game and released it in the
same
breath what I talking about the surprise
the Wonder that's what I like that's
what happens when you have a bunch
Studios today get it today January 25th
booya
baby oh Arcane okay here we go here we
go I just something evil is swallowing
up this place bit by bit bit by bit no
ever believes things can get this guys
it's just ever believes
these it's too late Them Bodies H stack
them well they literally said it's not
back for butter left no I know I was
joking everybody crying oh is your
sarcasm yeah slide up on you shotgun
blasting them miss out here we go
welcome to redfall Massachusetts where
the calm seas and sunny skies have been
eclipsed by a legion of
vampires redfall is a story-driven
shooter at its heart which can be played
single player or co-op with up to four
players
o I'm liking it choose your hero each
with their own unique abilities and form
the perfect vampire slaying Squad to
take back red Falls haunted
streets at Arcane we make games where
the world itself is as important as the
characters with redfall we take an
exciting step forward building a
lovingly detailed open world to deliver
our largest setting
Ever every inch of our open world
carefully handcrafted packed with
environmental explore the streets of a
quaint Island Town from the once
bustling downtown to the haunted forest
to the decimated seaside boardwalk and
gorgeously detailed
landmarks but it's not all danger all
the time there are safe places on the
island where you can rest up chat with
survivors and re outside the
house here we're at the fire station one
of your home
bases
this is one place you'll receive Miss
from
survivors there's something I need you
to do the Old Lighthouse in the bay it's
been used for over a century to keep
boats away from the coastline if we turn
it back on it's a warning to anyone
trying to come to redfall right now easy
right sway well the Lighthouse Keeper is
a real [__] joined up with those
cultist and took the damn lamp with them
oh she looking dope go all bird oh yeah
OD oh invisibility here a vampire known
as the Shroud shrouds blanket the area
in darkness disorienting their
prey they hurl lethal projectiles and
can even shift through the floor to
avoid damage
sh
nitic all right let's turn the difficult
up
mhm you go play on hard
I'mma play on touchy Philly pause pause
look at the house
though son oh no nope that's when I go
right outside
ncept the blood is part of me I am the
blood grandfather
clock V is coming
through the hell days
those oh ah I knew it I knew it felt
like it was a
very he bur burst get the bur one shoot
him with the steak shoot him with the
steak
oh and that's a bullet spongy uh vampire
right there bug it
out what you
[Applause]
at invisible dude be a problem
M shout out to my man hip hop
G the lighthouse is back up but there's
more waiting for you taking down
vampires angers the vampire Gods who
will summon the Rook to take you
down or B
R Who messing with the lighthouse
told you let's transition to what you'll
find outside of the main story missions
there's so much waiting for you redfall
is filled with encounters that can pop
up anywhere like this Brewery that's
Fallen under cultist control save the
locals from being offer to the
vampires like our past games you can
approach a mission in many different
ways oh that's that Arcane Salvage right
mhm approaches from different things yep
always be ready to impr
Remy uses her combat robot
bbon and eliminate
[Music]
the we got him I would say you know go
try out what was that other game if they
just put out uh death loot guns control
nice it's just that blood on the wall
son wall so why they got to Str you out
and put your blood on the wall spell
right versus on your blood got to C this
back
that this over
here infiltration
Mission silently feeling like a does
feel way
Aran yeah just all the op you how attack
different Mission get your man with the
on his back wow wow
preparation out here everyone's safe
let's move
on he's like y that hurt to have
exploring red ball will take you beyond
the bounds of reality as you investigate
otherworldly psychic spaces to unravel
the vampire Secrets take this vampire
Nest these deadly layers change each
time you step
inside Jacob sends out his Raven to tag
the enemies below Deb follows up with
his teleporter instantly closing the Gap
I like that dude you throw a teleporter
on the floor oh
up that thing do that shot
shot I like the combo move yeah unique
synergies
yeah to destroy a nest you have to take
out heart and all the vampires willing
to die to protect blood what you call it
horrible way to
die [__] I woke them up just
one I take you in the house clear out
the blood plag thing yeah that's what
called blood plag the plag I can say
this though um if anybody want to say
that it was like a left dead now Escape
The Nest before it comes crashing down
Chang form this is really story based
yeah it's just a lot more immersive not
just get to the safe room that it you
know yes nests AR the only psychic
spaces dangerous poket all over the
island yeah this is what we act for
right look at the world
carefully got you that gave me some BL
wh- she got you she red fall won't truly
be safe until the vampires are wiped
from the map outside the main story
another one of your missions is to take
back redfall neighborhood by
neighborhood find safe houses hidden all
over the island and then work your way
up to the vampire controlling the
neighborhood to reclaim this
neighborhood you'll have to defeat a
powerful vampire called the
siphon whether you dive in Solo or with
friends each hero can take on any
situation can see powerful abilities to
the fight and the upgrades you choose
change how they
play here ability can be upgraded to
launch teammates for Airborne attacks
upgrade Lea's umbrella ability with
bullet hail to absorb enemy bullets and
release the energy back at oh I like
that your man with the shot
radi get him
jump get his
there are many ways to customize your
hero's ability tree to match your play
style I'm sure they turn the difficulty
down just to show off the game play of
course because of well I'm going to play
on this mode anyway the Aral there's a
wide range of weap from
military shot to
snip who you can both they got Exotics
vampire stes find these in the world to
customize your weapons I got I like the
B that you know what I
feel with the jiger
jiger aor freeing people when youim
significant sections of redfall the last
step is to face the under boss who
controls or used to control that
neighborhood under bosses are powerful
Elites of the vampire Gods with their
own unique abilities this one's Shield
that
when you prove yourself against the
under boss you'll receive a key
of aull that get you one step closer to
facing the ultimate threat the vampire
Gods oh
man oh you're Landing
playing thank you for visiting redfall
and thank you for all the support you've
shown Arcane throughout the years we
sometimes that our games can be tough to
define the one thing that's consistent
we make the kinds of games we love to
play and that's how redfall was born we
Blended everything we love here at
Arcane Austin immersive open worlds
unique and customizable heroes RPG and
FPS and of course our signature
storytelling and ritual building along
with our spin one of the most classic
moners
of relasing it's been amazing to see how
all of us have pulled together to
deliver our vision for something new
redfall is the biggest most ambitious
game we have ever made our teams still
head first into this new opportunity and
we can't wait for you to experience
redfall for yourself thankfully you
won't have to wait too much longer
redf
May and porza is
2023 prob is probably November SE
so well I'm going tell you this if that
SP in September they going to get that
video oh they definitely coming in the
second half they just said 2023 that
just show me they no first half video
for
you these people
yeah oh Lord are you done no no he's
ready to talk about something what is
that on your
screen okay that is a stick of recycling
Last of Us Last of Us yeah what we doing
but these are bangers yeah yeah these
Spider-Man yes what's what's going on
bangers yeah blood boy what what are we
doing here sir bangers bangers yes oh
yeah rat CL definitely definitely
bangers bangers bangers yes Horizon get
to the point Sony gives you these
bangers yes these oh Spider-Man
definitely and you know we know what the
deal is about oh yes we know we know we
know what the deal is about yes the
original these these first party bangers
oh that's go yes bang no we we all I'm
just dying to knowwhere he's gone don't
know where all thought these first party
bangers were were sufficient and self-
sustaining we really find out it's all
about are you find out that y'all all
this all this all of this don't equal
this you not enough are you all this
that you brought right now don't matter
to them this dude this what the deal is
about they don't want the information to
come out that this ain't
worth all of this joint that y'all was
capping for meant nothing are you
implying that Sony themselves said that
they need Call of Duty to actually fund
their first party banggers because these
dud don't buy games
but this is where the fear lies in once
Call of Duty get over the
Xbox all of you guys is gone see that's
that's the poison pill this is what we
talking about here so the real
prize is a multiplat game that funds all
your fun all your fun all the stuff that
you like like to cap about all the stuff
that you like to talk about he
man this is what it is so now you going
to put some respect on it so now you
know why they were scrambling and
bambling why you know why oh oh they got
to block this deal by en necessary and
y' dud is like I don't even play Call of
Duty
anyway you know what you don't play Call
of Duty but you play these though right
and without this there's no this that is
true that is very true that is and we
about to take this away from
you no you messy so now all yall
snitching got you to talk about the
facts and the facts of the matter
is you
hiding you
deceitful you lying
D it's over over it's over over and it
ain't no concessions Gonna Save
You So now that we know this is worth
more to them than all of this that is
true all the money I put here don't
matter cuz this funds this take this
away this goes away I give him this this
is messy but this you want to up I can't
wait for it to happen I can't wait for
you to become
this yo come on K not the [__] they
gonna be an app going be app now come on
and we going to be able to download you
and play you anywhere
but what I do love is the facts is
coming out the truth sh you see you
can't block the sun with the thumb you
know you you can try to hide it you can
try to hide the Sun but it's always
Gonna Shine and the truth shall set you
free the truth shall come out at some
point in time so you can lie as much as
you want but now the paperwork is coming
up I want to see when Jim has to sit in
front of the Congress and be
like well um financially we in we in
cragmire but Call of Duty helping us out
fixing up stuff you know we got
Spider-Man funded
because because of Call of Duty I can't
wait to take that funding
away and see what you really about
without the
steroid
steroids see what you really could do
without
steroids are you really
homegrown oh oh you implying that's not
organic growth it's not organic because
you need the
stimulant you need the stimulus package
this is the Drake and you guys a got no
bars that's the secret
sauce all along who knew who knew who
was really the backbone
behind that's the real B that's the real
exclusive this is the real
Sony and you dudes are always not enough
you have never heard my so say yo
without Call of Duty we won't be able to
make God a war I mean Gears of War or
Halo or we won't be able to fund Forza
we find out that you guys can't stand on
your
own dude y'all dependent on this
drug why you think like they a drug
addict or something they like hey
man please don't take away that Call of
Duty man I can't but you this is prum M
about to make y'all go to a it's
over it's over y'all about to go cold
turkey and it's a rap I've waited for
this for so long why you wait you sound
like Megaton
bro K yourself I would have waited an
eternity I would have waited an eternity
Megatron talking to Optimus
falling I waited for the
come we've all seen the truth in the
background we've all seen it I don't see
none of these PlayStation dudes capping
no more I don't see nobody on my toeline
I told you in the end of the days this
is the end of
times it's been
prophesized the The Four Horsemen you
shall see the four horsemen when the
prophecy I don't like this energy and I
Am The Horseman of
war and I have commenced that Phil Phil
who's the is or Phil or ISU who's the
for yo now Phil Dominus Maximus aelia
Spencer has been dispatched down to you
yo you know what y'all was calling for
Phil to get out of here now I know why
y'all didn't want Phil around oh this is
the truth oh okay okay I see do I see
what you're doing now yeah Phil Phil is
the one he's the chosen one y'all just
was like nah man he need to get out of
there y seen things
happening it is
divine oh Odin wished it to be
so is old okay okay he released
September 6th the latest up tuing title
for Microsoft own Bethesda is getting
that new release they also announced
that the uh Starfield direct event will
now be on June 11th that's the same day
I believe as the Microsoft but that's
the Xbox but it should have came out but
go ahead I'm going to let you go first I
know this is contentious so um yeah they
just said uh that in the event how God
how it came out there he said in June
we're going to bring you into the studio
and give you a deep dive in the game at
our Starfield direct there's so much
that we still have to show you the
dedicated Starfield event will be again
follow the aiel showc so showcase that
event June 11 which has caused a bit of
a buzz and controversy on Twitter
there's a lot of feelings and you know I
think King has been very prophetic about
his feelings and dropped the early dis
record on Twitter about what is to come
so I'm going to shut up because this is
what the real waiting for they said Cog
shut up let him get his bars off and I
think we'll all go after K so K now that
we have the date of our star field and
we know how you feel prior how's this
how you resonated right now I was going
to do um a battle
rap I I literally was going to start it
off with like time time time and and
just go into a whole battle rap and then
I was just like n that's corny and then
you realized how much time that would
take it's not I'm don't listen to you
damn trench coat Mafia I don't listen to
you leave my man alone he took it off
though
he took it he did take it oh yeah he
said I'd rather have hard nipples than
have on I snapped my fingers and it just
disappeared um and then then I go back
and I looked I looked at that uh that
showcase three times three times I went
back and looked at the Showcase 30 games
this hasn't been done in 20 years you
know the 12 month thing then I watch the
podcast over again I podcast right after
and S was like that's an unnecessary
rake and I'm like man shut up and was
like but they painting your in the
corner I'm like oh man shut up
like get out of here with that soft talk
soft talk no it's just all about the
Kool-Aid stuff came later okay it's all
about yeah go sorry having respect for
for those people because you know
microsof is a kid that you see him
trying hard but he just don't have that
athleticism you know he's on the
baseball team but don't have like you
know you got the Derek J everything come
easy to them you know and they getting
the accolades and they trying but he
trying hard too you know sometime he
stumbles like he's running to the base
and he's going real hard cuz he practic
all week but he trip right at the end
you like he get called out you know but
Microsoft was always
trying this is all on you bro I told you
make your
date 30 games you
showed 10 of them don't got dates as a
hell of a l bro that is a hell of an l i
and and I don't care don't tell me oh
you know we we took the time out for the
30 to the you know it was Todd ready
before it was Todd ready last year right
and everybody
knew going in that you put a Target on
your back now I don't I know you're
going to say oh we don't have control
over third party Studio games like
stalker 2 we don't have control over
Hollow Knight we don't have control then
you shouldn't have put 12 months up yeah
you let's say that person that went in
and said oh snap 12 months this what
I'mma get I'mma pay my 12 months of Game
Pass right
now they counted on those 12 months like
you said those games are going to be
there you didn't get on stage and say we
estimate not one time that was later
when the Tweet went out estimated was at
the bottom but when you was on stage and
let's say I'm Ray
Charles that I didn't read the fine
print but I just listened to the show on
a podcast right and you said 12 months
this is what you gonna play has been
done and everybody's rallying behind you
it was a great show it was a hell of a
show but 10 of the most important games
are't there the other games are there
but the 10 most important games the 10
pillars of your show ain't in there so
who's the L for the L is for you you I
told you you was going to get this smoke
Starfield slip you going to get this
work where the hell is bza so obviously
if Starfield is in September where the
hell is PA what's Forza date oh it looks
60 frames you thought you was gonna shut
me up cuz it looks 60 frames give it to
Todd 30 like Todd said and get it out
and give the patch because you know you
know Cog and
sa said releas the 30
frames I don't I don't care I don't care
about the you don't care if the game
runs theity of the game I don't care no
I'm with I'm with adct on this because
addict says I just care about the
results so you ain't gonna have it both
way adct you're not g to say oh I want
just the results I don't care what what
is holding you up I don't care what is
wrong I don't you told me 12 months and
I think the measure of a company and the
measure of the people is how they stick
to their word I supported you this whole
time I'm the one that have faith
remember I'm the one that put up a
picture a tweet that said I think it's
going to launch on time so I gotta front
line this right you didn't come out and
say yo you know what we definitely
messed up keep mad cuz he jumped
outside it's your professional
relationships affecting this decision
yes stupid you see it right here the
fact that you were whing and dining with
Todd Howard a part of this sir yes yes I
looked into his Bab blue
eyes and he said to me King don't worry
got you it's ship on time did not know
your time was
September I've been Bo win to let it
straight for the W Chris as we go we we
meet these gentlemen at the game ofs and
then I go up Todd I'm like yo TD take
your time bro stop don't worry about K
was like yo you got to be a man of your
word you got to be a man you said 12
so this was in the we saying this to to
Howard and it's hilarious cuz King shut
me down he's like yo you better be about
your work the I love I love the idea of
Todd Howard uh and you guys are like the
angel and devil on his shoulder like
telling him like oh man we no you got to
make 12 months he like no you gotta make
sure it's good it doesn't matter if you
just like
arguing no I I mean this this whole look
it's it's it is disappointing to me that
they uh that they are going to miss yet
another date it's it's always irritating
when this happens but to me I'm like bro
don't just don't announce a date until
you're sure you know what I mean like
this all of this stuff could be like I I
no longer assume like anytime somebody's
like oh game's coming out April 15th I'm
like oh cool so like September yeah
right like all every time like I always
like what's what's a reasonable delay
like four months something like that
like okay and I autoc correct the date
to that and it's usually right like
almost all the time it's like it's
actually crazy almost every game has
been delayed at one point yeah release
dates mean nothing to me now like
because they clearly just announce them
before they're ready and before they're
even sure that they're going to hit them
and so to me it's to me it's it's not an
issue of pushing the game to September
it's a matter of having that date be
moved so consistently just don't give a
date and people wouldn't have a problem
with this I I I I will always be in
favor of a delay because I've seen dude
the the amount of the the state that
Halo infinite launching is so
unacceptable I I I really can't I I
really can't believe to them like how
mismanaged that project was given how
important that that that IP is how long
ago was that recent history the G that
recent history Chris I'm just saying dop
the campaign was dope oh now
you campaign was messy bro it's a
frustrating thing because like that's
it's like a you play you play Halo
infinite it's like this is actually a
great game but it's like damn If Only
They had just given it that extra time
so that it could have landed the way it
should have and that game's not really I
I don't see it really recovering ever
any any repairable damage they just
launched the I heard they just launched
you know season of the Fallen yeah
whatever and dudes is over there having
fun I don't know man it's fine yeah the
new season where um where the frame rate
issues are happening on Console now all
crazy it's a it's a mess man and it's
just like it's again it's not the worst
thing that it's ever been but it like it
didn't have to be this way so like if
and Starfield is the most important game
that Xbox has I go I don't even need to
be here today Chris here continue I'm
sorry
you told you that you was going to get
12 months give me the money money
100% but I think it's I think it's
better for them to I think it's better
for them to suffer the short-term damage
of like okay we missed the date we
missed the date than it is for them to
put this game out before it's ready when
it's clearly the most important game
that they have right now
refh everything everything is writing on
Starfield and I mean that every had an
ally for a whole two minutes how I feel
I feel like they looked at me and said
how do we keep an idiot in
suspense here here's my thing with it I
I do feel like oh give Microsoft that
smoke they did make they set
expectations they uh they gave you dates
that you know realistically they didn't
know that they could keeping out
especially from like a third party point
of view but at the same time as much as
I overwhelmingly want the game to come
out more than I care about their dates
like I I I want the game to come out
not broken then I care about their days
I want the game to come out the best Li
yeah here's here you like them to lie to
you no that's not the that's not the
point I care about the the health of of
Starfield and whether or not this game
comes out in in a busted State a Halo
State more than I care about them
telling me something I don't care what
they say I want the game to be the best
so the next time you order your food and
they say they we be there in 15 minutes
now never going have that same energy
right they told you going to be there 15
minutes with your food and they get that
hour and a half but they say yo it's
going to be better
though so so they they give me that food
they give me that food they they say
they G get me that so it's it's
equivalent having someone call me be
like yo I get you that food in 15
minutes but it's gonna be
raw minutes this is why this is this is
why I order my food three days before
I'm hungry there you
go just in case don't want to hold these
dudes by the rule of the law no I
literally said y if you want to give
them the smoke you have every right to
give them the smoke but I I care more
about Starfield as a game than I care
about what they said I care more about
the lion I care more about the lion
don't lie to me and tell me yo if
somebody tell you yo you go to the
mechanic they say your car is going to
be ready tomorrow and it's 2 weeks later
yo what's up with my car
oh it's going to be much better drive
they're like yo your car going be ready
tomorrow you getting that thing drive
down the road break like bus and fall
off the and die
car you gave me half a car we good that
don't mean s's up to Sol's knowledge of
the game it's gonna come out broken in
September oh it will oh listen I don't
trust
September yeah I I'm I'm I'm with S I
don't I don't I Pro I I would put money
I would put money on September not being
the I I bet I bet something's but like
the here's here's the real problem right
is is Starfield is like it is it will
reshape how the future looks for the for
Xbox if if if Starfield comes out and
it's a botched mess and I'm not talking
about like Bethesda Jank you know like
there's a certain amount of Bethesda
Jank that people are going to appreciate
there's even some that I'm probably like
a little bit excited for to be honest
with you like I like I like that
honestly but if it's if it's busted like
beyond recognition and if it does not
meet expectations and make no mistake
expectations for this game are super
high this is like I think I feel like
Starfield is has come as close to as
talk it it's it's talk it the
expectations on Starfield are like
nearly like halflife three levels where
it's like the this needs to be this
needs to be great because if it's not
then everybody's going to be like what
the [__] is going on with Fable then
sorry sorry to Cur again what is going
on with Fable what's going on with Fable
like what the hell's going on with but
you don't have Todd on Fable we know
what Todd is see everybody this is
really a Todd thing you gotta keep a
buck like if Todd and Bethesda was
allowed to do what Todd and Bethesda do
this game would have came out already I
I feel like mikrosoft has two lanes that
they got to prove for this this game
starf for they got two to justify the
beginning of all these these you know
these purchases which is Bethesda why we
bought Bethesda we bought Bethesda for
games like Starfield uh you know then
they got to prove that you know not only
did we by Bethesda because I I do think
they have to Pro to people why they're
investing so much money into the
ecosystem they also got approved and
we're going to actually help make a
better Bethesda we're we're going to
cure The Fallout 76 illness that they
have and I think that these two lanes
are very rough to navigate through and
all it would take as this game come out
in in a real bad state they're like okay
it don't matter they bought Bethesda
they they're going to make nothing but
Fallout 76 for the rest of our lives and
if the game comes out then okay it
doesn't matter if they invested what's
the point in investing in Activision
investing into those Studios you know
the initiative stuff when they're like
they can't even get Starfield right why
can't they get any of these games right
Fable up for chopping block it's going
to make the
managing argument way worse something
else something else to consider too is
that the expectation for Starfield is so
high that even if it is really good I
feel like people are going to be harsh
on it anyway so so it needs to be better
than it needs to be better than amazing
yeah no that's a fact so we got to get
that's it's it's it's a rough it's a
rough I I do not envy I do not envy Todd
Todd's position absolutely do IP and all
that Sol your thoughts on yes sir King
has so so first I must apologizing
apologize for switching my stance
anytime I I side with King on anything I
fly too close to the Sun
andash I should have stuck to my soft
talk a really track record man yes bad
track Rec
96 96 percentile coming down by we got
to bring him down to 80 this this this
is all fil this ain't this ain't Todd oh
this is all Phil heed to this all 100%
Phil Phil went in there looked at his
build and said
no no and and Todd is like yo my I know
my audience my audience know I'mma come
with a little bit of Jank she like no is
we like y'all saying right now the talk
that I hear oh this game has to be God
it can't miss it is never going to hit
those expectations whatever the
expectations are it's going to be some
people out there one or two people
that's going to be like this is the
greatest game to ever hit this Earth and
they're going to be fighting people over
it but the the majority of the people is
goingon to be like it's a good Bethesda
game it's a good fall I like Fallout 2
better than then that's when the whole
comments is going to start coming out
but it's never going to reach those
lofty expectations did you say Fallout
too yeah he did but we going to move on
I said we can tell his love for this
series
it's so so yeah like so so Chris for
context like I you know I had normal
take that that's a normal
people I don't
care I you know I said there's no I'm a
stream marker so I remember it yes
please they should have never put a date
on it the moment they delayed it they
should have just said 2023 that's it and
and drop it in the in the fall and
that's it right but I I got excited by
high five r
I'll be honest I I felt that there was a
confidence I'm like wait a minute they
dropping this I'm like Rush was awesome
yes it was absolutely so out ofwhere and
they gave you that because they knew
they wasn't giving you the rest of those
games one thing I knock them for is that
they they they don't know how to do the
mic drop moment the real mic drop moment
the way PlayStation likes to drop mics
they don't really do that well and I'm
like maybe they have it here they
they're so confident high-f five rush to
hell with it I think we're going to get
Starfield we're going to it'll be March
April we're going
to this is all backtracking yeah I love
this this great I got Ked I'm I'm
acknowledging this these two killed me
it would be came at us hard we bro no
don't say these two all I did was change
sides
I in in in the theater in in the
event more oh that's right watch that me
and him both were coming at you well it
wasn't solve at first it was ke bro and
then and then you you you converted Sol
a couple weeks later later exactly later
but but but
look I'm G tell you right now I don't
trust September either and I will go
back to it these games a bgs game could
literally be worked on forever and not
be bug free so you agree K 100% like no
I age told me it was going to come out
whenever whenever it because according
to it don't matter when it releases no
no no I do not no no I'm going back I'm
going I'm going back to where I belong
in
land drink the
Koolaid you know don't don't get caught
up
with don't get caught the gangsters over
there come over here soft talk Su but
I'm tell you right now I I I think if
the game got delayed again that's where
I'm King side but I I go back to and
Chris said it perfectly and I've said
this a million times as well it has to
be a business consideration why they
keep putting dates onto these games that
do not they know full well they're not
going to hit it doesn't make any sense
to me because you just keep looking bad
just don't put a date on it you know
what it is though let's be real like
they went into last year and people
saying yo we want more gameplay and we
want dates we want gameplay and we want
dates and I think they their mindsets
like we don't know if this game can
realistically hit this this this time
frame that's why they didn't give Street
dates they just gave a time period but
we got to tell them some form of time
period because if they would have came
on stage last year let's be real and
gave a bunch of games with no time frame
whatsoever they would have they would no
one would have cared anything that was
shown if they if they show if they show
gameplay that's excite excites me I
don't really care about the day no but
people to add point I think would have
been like yo they would have obliterated
here's the thing here's the thing people
probably would have but the issue is the
issue isn't even necessarily putting a
date on things before you know that
you're ready to put it out the issue is
showing your games too early in the [__]
in the first place like it it is like
why why did you talk about El the next
Elder Scrolls three years ago like don't
do that what like we how long ago did we
see the first teaser trailer for fable
three years ago was it three years ago
19 19 201 20 it is
2023 we still have no word on fa why did
you do that I'm going to be honest I'd
rather the silence I'd rather complete
silence and shock me six months before
the game's about to come
out that's that's what mean we we we saw
vow uh I mean we we have some form of
hope that you know maybe hell blades end
of the year beginning of next year but
you know that's not even
really br
to be honest King with your track record
I wouldn't believe it either so you you
can stop trying to come for me put your
put your trench code back on
I'm you just it's not my fault you keep
going out the street my fa you keep
jumping
out you jump out parachute they
complaining I got to get my bars off
please I'll scare you back um put that
back on your face hide your face the
problem is I don't I don't I trust I
don't trust them anymore I don't trust
them this is the only industry where
they could give you a date and we we're
cool with it right and they can switch
it up we don't take that from anything
your Uber five minutes late dudes is
getting one Stars
right this is literally yo y'all don't
settle for this in nothing your your
girl upstairs getting ready and she's
like y' I'll be down in 10 minutes an
hour later you Furious y'all in the car
you're not talking you're just driving
you got to get to oh could you tell your
wife that y going to get married
September 6 and he like nah we GNA do
this in
December there's nothing there's nothing
that we for this for but here you go
your heart pumping Kool-Aid and you
dudes ain't calling these dudes to the
carpet
no just fact like because we don't
calling
about we we called them out but we
understand why they do you act like it's
got to be one or the other I don't
understand just cuz you're the one that
jumped out the
plan don't mean we don't have
parachute talking fortim you talking for
little timy you talking for little for
little Timmy that that that mowed that
lawn and got that money up
that for the game pass ultimate he said
Phil dominance
Maxim stupid Game Pass Ultimate Will
have 30 games all these games Starfield
red for everything I'm going to be
playing Forza in the next 12 months what
if he only got 12 months to live you up
we doing the can St too oh we doing he
could have been over there with and he
going sit here and wait 12 months and
you ain't gonna give him what he
needs you out of pocket stop you expires
in June he got he got September he don't
got a September but you made Timmy sit
down and wait he gave you his Game Pass
money and loud what up N I don't I'm not
about this I don't like this you lied on
stage 10 games that ain't coming out
where is that oh EXO skeleton where's
the where's the robot dinosaurs at oh oh
yeah I remember that one EXO meca Primal
I think it's called no there's another
one that K was talking about too there
was another one that L like Dino Bots
and silver Sur really yeah it was some
like Battle Royale joint yeah it's not
EXO Primal primal the
Capcom there was another joint from the
third party Xbox third party show I know
what king talking about was oh King that
came out already F Carole that no yeah
it came it was in Early Access the
dinosaur thing dinos and everybody was
silver silver that joint meca yeah XA I
don't think it came not that crap that
you talking about no X it's the one with
with it's in early you just not a beta
boy but it's an early
come out yet didn't come out where's
Hollow Knight where's flint lock it's
it's mad games I went back looking I was
like oh yeah y'all slick so right now I
feel like how do you keep an idiot in
suspense you tell them 12
months and then and then when you got no
other recours when you gonna announce
your show in June this the only reason
why we got September date because oh the
show is gonna be in June why because you
want to protect Diablo you know the the
the better thing we could talk about too
is the fact that that showcase is the
same day the
same that's concerning that makes me
lowy think that that might be in that
showcase and take a take some they said
it's separate but me to me why would you
do it the same day why why wouldn't you
do it before going into the show unless
you you're going to direct people and a
lot of the hype's going to be at that
towards that show like they going have
less you think they going to have less
because of they they're going to have
less I feel like they might not have a
like the the stuff that they necessarily
want to show and they're going to direct
some of of that height towards it okay
you know we we showed you this and I
know some of you might like it some of
you might not but we got the Starfield
thing in 30 40 minutes that you can
watch month to me are you going to do it
before the show as like a pre-show then
I okay I can understand that a little
bit but if it's after the show after it
see to me what is why why are you going
to have something like that after the
show to take away from the the spotlight
of your show like yeah we got to see I
mean I'll jump in if I if I can't
so yeah I'm done yeah look um from a
pure perple standpoint we know King is
right from a pure principle standpoint
yeah just the principle of it you don't
have your word you have nothing I get
that you know what I'm say and to
Chris's point this is all self-inflicted
like you have no business going out
there saying that whatever you see here
is going to for the next 12 months
you're going to get and and that's why
if you remember CG's been on the record
when everybody was like yo that 12b
format is no it's not fire because the
reason why I don't like it is one you
take away the Wonder and the M drop
moments like s is talking about the
magic that could happen right that's
what make a Nintendo show yo I can't
believe they drop you know what I'm
saying at the end same thing with the
Sony oh man so I I hated that then you
put undo pressure that these games
better come out in the 12 otherwise you
going to have King out here doing what
king do making disre unnecessary
pressure that could have been completely
took away now where King loses me is
games get delayed every day be like like
like literally you know what I'm saying
so like God of War what about Timmy life
I feel that but Timmy died Waiting for
God of War Ragnarok in
2021 Timmy died waiting for Zelda breath
of the wild 2 in 2022 y Timmy's dying a
lot Timmy got this like a bats you know
that that's a TV show right now bats
sitcom people waiting
for it's just the same it's just the
same child waiting and dying before a
video game comes out it's like a
graveyard of dead Timmy like rest in
peace Timmy X died waiting for
Starfield bringing them back you know
what though you know I I really feel bad
it's like the prestige Timmy Edition
right you know we feel bad for Timmy but
I feel bad for little Timmy's mom losing
the said Timmy die every day B like
that's just what it is we've been
outside we know how this go the rules
the level of copium is crazy I here's
the thing this is the only place that
y'all will accept listen we not you
could be you could be G you got to read
that super chat for Frank Castle
all right we breaking protocol $5 Super
Chat come on let's be real make a wish
Timmy is using that lamp for Spider-Man
2 instead of Starfield let the boy die
with a
smile y y Messing not regrets look man
the health and quality over the game
yeah comes over people's feelings over
taking pictures with people get the
money back you know what say comes over
that tweet on the title screen on the
screen you know what I'm saying at
war look they messed up they didn't they
didn't they didn't execute their target
as king said you want to say lying what
absolutely right but at the end of the
they rightful to get the smoke they're
rightful to get it CU self-inflicted but
this is my thing when I watch The Joint
I'm looking at what I see and what I I
look over TD's
shoulder now what I remember what I
recall there was a lot of 30 frames per
second energy Chris R
the first the first time we saw it like
that part right there with the comat I
don't know you know what I'm saying
everything else the scope grandios oh
you got space comp okay but you do
looking like you diry energy and
remember me and you we had you on d we
had you know what saying we talked about
we did the crossover and we was like
What if it's sturdy though and you were
like bro I don't know if I can do this
sturdy like N I cannot you know what I'm
saying so for me I look at what I just
saw and I'm like you saw that
Runner it look like some 60 FPS I don't
know I saw a lot of Xbox controllers in
front of PC hey hey hey I just like that
it was moving faster than what it was
moving before I mean I think I think we
all could I I think the uh you know the
the the master race knows that it was
going to run on 60 on PC factual fact
Tod Howard is going to announce
35 there we go everybody or they can do
the 41 cuz y'all do engage engage VR R
you know you be fine God so look at the
end of the day this my thing you know
what I mean and I hate to call for for
y'all but do not let this game be a 90
plus met critic do not let this game be
fire I am going to be on y'all because
for all this come out the8 if all this
smoke after y'all ain't learned from
Halo infinite and this game get delayed
and it's actually fire it's a Game of
the Year Contender I want all of y'all
to keep the same energy I want you to
keep the same energy stand on your
Square support not don't pick it up when
we over there celebrating popping
bottles you don't pick it up you're not
allowed all y'all complaining is
unacceptable you can't do it this is I
got stand go to change.org and say we
are not buying this game despite the
lending money because they should have
kept their word and we will be over
there playing
game got my money I'm getting my play
through you are a against they are not
about you should stay on the side and
your this hold up real quick I I need us
to put in stone right now what
determined this Metacritic thing if it's
like a if it is do we only win car if
it's a 90 above I think that's a
huge hard 82
if this a 8889 king is coming for our
next 85 whatever 82 I want them to teach
Xbox a lesson and I want them to stay on
the sideline I want I don't want to see
them I don't want to see my friendless
Starfield I want you to be a man of your
convictions math I'm just saying Co math
ain't in your
favor everybody Under the Sun is going
to review this game and that only brings
the number down I'm just saying saying
all I'm saying is don't let it be great
for one I'm happy if it's an 87 I'm just
saying don't let it be said 90
plus all I'm saying if it is and this is
God Howard brown leather jacket Skyrim
energy uhuh yeah I won't be looking for
y'all same dude man I'm on life support
right here all I hear is the
beat but look that's all I got I mean at
the end of the day I I saw the trailer
it looked like it's doing a lot of stuff
man I like
different at the end of the day you got
to take it at the end of the day you
don't
right money pay these first bills and
then we'll pay the second bill so do not
turn off your mics congregation cuz I
will be referring to you guys
momentarily M all right that's what's up
Santa Baby the season 4 fresh cut is
find Lee here here with the sponsors of
today's show mancate the leaders in
below the waist grooming have just
launched their fifth generation lawn
mower to help you avoid another silent
night in the bedroom this year take care
of your special snowflake with manscaped
and watch your South Pole shine like
never before get the best stocking
stuffer of all by going to manscape.com
and using code ironlord for 20% off plus
free shipping Mrs Claus will thank you
so let me defer to my panel here in this
season of giving gentlemen is there
anyone that you want to gift with the
the the the the beauty of a shiny pole y
cool
yo let me go to you got to go to me I
can't even play the music go to Cognito
first look man you know it's the seasons
you got season giving season givings and
you got to make sure the tree is tried
right tree you gota you know you gotta
you got to make sure everything's right
you know what I'm saying so I get my
manscaped on and you know there's a lot
of people out there again a lot of mass
swords that ain't right out here and if
you want your
partner to be happy during the holiday
season make sure you get your poll your
situation corrected that's all I got
movie going had to go to cuz he sounded
so disgusting so disgusting with this
man I was like how you going do me like
that Lord King how about you sir anybody
anybody is going to be uh find a
beautiful gift from manscaped under the
tree although for whoever maybe you
don't celebrate right giving seon I
don't celebrate it but um I do give out
gifts for the soltice so so so this is
during that same period of time M I was
just talking about this the other day oh
right all right because wifey was like
um do you have any more of that band
scape stuff from my brother there we go
and I was like why is he
unapt and then the second question
listen listen and then the second
question was how you know this like so
now definitely I was like um I got some
stuff and I'm gonna definitely order
some stuff for him I said the
underwear's dope oh bro Addy got a story
add could contribute for that
one had got a real good story on
manscape for that one yeah so that stuff
is super dope so I'm sending him a
little package of manscape and I know
he's going to enjoy it because I enjoy
it yes every week I enjoy it facts Lord
addict the underwear story this sh so
when me and my girl talking about like
Christmas stuff uh yeah she I I ended up
getting her like an Apple Watch and she
was like well what do you want and I was
like I just want some manscape hun yo I
a go for that the man Gap boxes is
official bro silky she she ended up uh
getting me like eight or nine
something so I was like yeah just like
look man like she like how to package
not even not not even just keeping you
know the the master sword uh you know
upkept man if you want to use the master
sword you might want to upcut you and
also how you present your master sword
to your loved one right you got the
manscape UN after you handled your
business that's what's up man I respect
if you two want to get nine pairs of
manscape underwear just use code iron
Lord
that that discount
facts their stuff is is is extremely
good but I'm going to be real with you
guys that that underwear man always like
like I've always sweated everywhere it
don't matter where it is but that that
that is like the best underwear I've
ever that just felt comfortable no
matter moist yeah it's moisture Wick
silk all right so what could be better
than giving the gift of good hygiene in
a few laps starting with the lawn mower
5.0 Ultra this is the Crown Jewel of the
holidays and dare I say the best ball
trimmer of all time the electric razor
Advanced Skin safe technology is a
lifesaver and known for reducing Nicks
and cuts on his Santa sack but the fun
doesn't stop there anybody in the family
have too much scruff look no further
than manscapes beard hedger Pro kit and
handyman electric face shaver for all of
the facial needs does dad have nasty
nose hairs saved a day with the weed
whacker 2.0 oh those are M nose and ear
hair trimmer yes as we get older hair
just grows out of places that you didn't
know you had man and the the weed
whacker 2.0 nose and ear hair trimmer
get the job done now also is their boxer
game week take care of the chestnuts
with manscapes two boxers 2.0 featuring
their signature Jewel pouch to keep you
calm cool and collective's been very
calm lately yeah I'm telling you guys
man you guys ever wonder how I've calmed
down I'm not as aggressive as I used to
be aggressive for for for for every
Angry man there is man you know there
there's H for every you actually would
be for every non angry man man there's a
there's a pair of manscape underwear to
calm that that I almost C sack down Cal
your
sack aggressive
sack why his sack is that aggressive it
need to be C got a wild s you got a wild
and now this is new to the family have
their nails seen better days manscaped
has you covered with their new shears
3.0 nail grooming kit oh we got the man
and the P they got they got they got
everything they got to send my stuff I
need the in the P head to toe they have
you covered so right now we go get 20%
off and free shipping with the code iron
Lords at manscape.com that's Lords with
s right s yes with an S with an S that's
20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code iron Lords say
ho ho ho to a well-groomed mistletoe
with
manscaped salute salute I have to get up
on that we got to get up on that right
there what the you know what man you you
know it they would be more effective we
had women a lot of women that watch our
show because it' be a good gift man
you can get your girl you y you can get
your girl your stuff for for for her
Christmas present oh they don't be
caring about that they they don't care
about that they don't everything's
unisex to them they don't yeah that's a
fact I found out the I prefer I prefer
to she going like that you you that
St present yourself salute no doubt we
what's
happening all
rightless jelly
I want you to get a line are you hurt or
are you
injured you got shot are you hurt or are
you
injured there's a difference oh no if
you're hurt get up dust yourself off and
get right back outside and
fight five star general woo I see you
this is
war can't now we know the opposition has
a better Navy than us who the hell going
to go fight them in the water you'll be
a
fool tell opposition on the other side
has a better and superiority Ted hunt we
won't fight them in the
air you'll be a
fool we have a better
infantry we going to take them to the
ground and drown them in the water we
going to beat them to death on the
ground our
way you don't go inside a fight trying
to fight Muhammad Ali by outboxing him
bars you're not going to Beat the Champ
trying to be the champ the way The champ
is yeah you have to be you coming for S
get
him at no point in time am I going to
stand there for you pencil pushing
yellow belly s [__] that keep running
for the hills got be every time
something goes wrong you call fulfill
Dominus Maximus aelia job he is the only
one taking hard-hitting questions he
outside you just saw Anakin turn into
Darth Vader they making a good boy go
evil he said how I he he I'm
grumpy I'm I do apologize for being
Snappy With
You Ain't No More Mr Nice field oh
that's
it what we doing y'all keep acting like
this ain't the dude that brought us back
from the brink factual people do forget
you dudes was not worried about being an
Xbox Channel until I stood up and gave
you something to stand for talk to a
King let him know now you guys are in my
DM King what will we do we will hold the
line let's go let's go King you weak
dudes make me
sick can't do a
pushup can't do a
CH I seen you frauds making channels
feel [__]
for what cuz a red fo behind you
go shout out to be they trying they're
trying toire the biggest games
going they ain't trying to be number
one they ain't acting like they
belong when you got number one acting
like number three snitching and rat
snitching and telling that's what they
was doing you can't handle the work you
were getting worked in the field so you
had to go snitch they worried about
number
three they have mustard agents out there
they using they they got different
things theyit they got split to cells
they doing tactics on you Phil did
allude to tactics though I will give you
that let me tell you something Phil a
lot of you ignorant guys out there y
watched it you heard it you came across
with your own
narrative Phil told you in so many ways
with what these dudes are doing in the
background my hands are tied so I must
learn how to fight this way bars he did
allude to that I got to give you that he
did for the first time allude that the
others are doing things from their
position that to not help them get to
the I will give you that continue them
silent little
contracts don't put it on Game Pass
don't talk to
Xbox stay away from them kick SE it's
some extra
dough that's all we got to do is go out
and buy a whole dag on
building but then you go out and you
snitch oh man you ain't the Sony that I
know so we can't beat you regular up
squabbling we got to throw dirt in your
eyes don't squabble you guys make me
sick to my stomach we asking fulfilled
job don't come back I don't want to see
you over here when Starfield drops and
they give that n out of 10 and your
faces back in the building talk about I
always knew you could do it there a lot
of fraudulent Xbox dudes that's what we
doing we hold it a lot okay the drop oh
you the racing
K lot dud G switch sides you you've been
beating Gran Turismo what happened when
Gran Turismo launch H AG launch I a see
y'all out there talking about which
Jim's
job you actively rep a
rat you would know a standup dude if he
smacked you in the mouth and he did on
that interview we kind of
funny get him that's a real man standing
up there taking his medicine and he told
you I'm grumpy I'm upset but I'm sitting
right here I ain't ducking no Fades he
ain't duck to fade I give you that I
give you you don't see Jim
anywhere he actively ducking Fades all
right but what K but K what if you say
yo if you succeeded Jim don't need to be
outside cuz he giving them great gangs
he L let me tell you something you are
not going to make a game tomorrow that's
going to win the
war you can set building blocks and
building
traps you go out there you make the best
game that you can you don't stifle
creativity inside your building fil did
say that you make those people put out
the best product I can tell you this
they never make another red fall again
so we learned now we good now hopefully
but what's up with you guys making games
that run good that didn't succeed in
your folding stuff we'll get to that
later oh we talking about but I want you
to have the same energy open okay call
for
Jim don't you call for Phil okay it's
actually all adct topic we gonna set him
up on redfall the the reviews have hit
the streets the the after bath we he
Lords of gaming.net mmon also reviewed
the game and uh yeah let's look
currently sitting on Metacritic at a 59
currently and um yeah there's a lot of
talk right now there's the the the
internet is in a frenzy the X house
Community is in a frenzy about the game
so let's get to it let's get to it I
want to start with um start with Ben man
I mean obviously you def finic Dukes you
know thoughts on it but like what was
your thought process and did you get a
chance to to try redfall what do you
think of all the backlash and the
aftermath regarding the reviews of
redfall yeah I played for I don't know
four or five hours on releasee night uh
with some buddies
and it's it's interesting because
redfall is the kind of game I would
normally like set up and play with
somebody's for a little while but it's
not the kind I'm not that's not really
my style like I I liked you know back
for blood yeah I'm just mainly thinking
of these like four player Mission based
kind of games like I liked it because I
was playing with the Buddies like that's
a lot of my gaming experience now is
just playing with the dudes and I I
enjoyed that aspect of it or I enjoy
that aspect of gaming most and so like
for that reason I was interested in it
but as more and more stuff kept coming
forward as we got closer I was like I
don't know like I don't know you know
hearing hearing you guys you and saw who
went and saw it talk about it along with
Maddie and then like just seeing some
other you know little little leaks of
stuff trickle out I was like I don't
know but I'm still going to play it like
we set up a time to play we're going to
get on as soon as it's out definitely
going to play it and I was
just absolutely floored by how bad of a
time it was I had a great time again
hanging out with the with the guys
trashing it like we were just you know
trashing it the whole time we were
playing it
and this is like before all the reviews
were even out so it wasn't even like it
was more of a maybe it was a
confirmation bias that I thought it was
going to be bad and then it wasn't very
good yeah but I was just amazed at one I
got a I've never had a problem running
games on my computer at all and by the
way sorry King I'm I'm I'm with sa I'm
mostly a PC Gamer these days
but you know y y have horrible uh you
know performance got to tweak and twerk
you know to get yourself work TW it's
okay you know we over here look over at
yall admire you you know you know that
dude that when he's not invited to the
party he hates on
it Ain ain't nobody famous going to be
there I don't care
K is that VIP ha
dway the club is exclusive nobody can
get in there you sound like a
PlayStation fan like anybody can go and
purchase to get in nobody want to do the
effort you got date the same girl but
you're selling the same you know what it
is you you know what it may perform poly
but the thing is my game actually looks
like what your Nostalgia is going to
tell you in 10 years that your game
like you know what you did you paid that
price for it did I told listen I told
her I told her to come downstairs and
sweatpants and a
T-shirt and she apped you told her to
put on red bottoms and we went to the
same
Denny that is true that is true I know a
VIP SE over there with same check I was
wearing some some BLX to the Denny
that's true
Den y just
continue I was just I was disappointed
in every way about the game I thought it
it didn't look as good as it could it
didn't run as well as I thought it
should it was empty it was a little
confusing honestly like I start and and
I'm the kind of guy that if I know I'm
going to play a game and that's pretty
much anything on Game Pass and like 80%
of other games that aren't on Game Pass
if I know I'm going to play it I see the
first trailer I'm out if I don't know
that I'm going to play it I'll watch
until I decide I'm going to play it y
like that's so I didn't know really
anything about the game so I don't know
if this was shown but like basically
right after you do like the first thing
in the game you like you free some
prisoners and then you or some like they
were just hiding out and then you build
a base and I was like what's happening
are we like looking at the past year
like you got these these terrible cut
scen AR cut no Cinema just PowerPoint
slides like they aren't even they aren't
even Google Drive slides they're 199
power not the not the office
97 he hit us B hit us with the office 97
so
no clippy with that you to flip oh
man clippy in that game damn so no I'm
just
overall very disappointed and I wasn't
even excited that's how bad it was to me
like this was a game I was like I'm
looking forward to that but not excited
yeah
and then I play it and I'm like well now
I'm mad that I was even looking forward
to it like you know that that kind of
thing and the the worst part of about
redfall to me is there's something there
yes there's something there this could
be an awesome game but it doesn't run
right it's boring it's empty and I walk
up to a vampire and he just stares at me
and like I don't I don't know like the
AI is not good and I think the most
disappointing part overall and I know
this is a tired thing no let's go but
that a good Studio made it yeah you know
and maybe maybe making a game this bad
means you're not as good of a studio
anymore maybe that's what it means I
don't know but prior to this games I
played and games I didn't play were all
revered highly yeah and whether some of
that's revision this history with prey
everybody pretending like they liked it
when we know I was there yeah he was
there red red flat B okay I got you yeah
I was I remember not everybody liked
that game like they like it now uh but
it just it's disappointing to see
you know uh a potential in a game and
then a studio that you know has made
better games just just be disappointing
and and boring empty uh buggy and maybe
some of that gets better down the line
but I'm not I I played for five hours of
it and the next day my buddy was like
you thinking you think you going to play
redf fall anymore I was like well I
already deleted it so no not now maybe
when they maybe later but not now I feel
that no that's that's honest I hate we
at brother let's get Lords gaming.net
own editor and chief B moon in the
building way look brother you know you
we we got it for the
site being in the 11th hour but uh oh
yeah we were able you know shout out to
you you have tremendous uh tips and
checks initially for the you know person
who is new to experience the game for
the first time to survive but you know
you reviewed the game you know what' you
give it and also just your your overall
assessment of this whole situation
because it it really a blood bath out
here as far as you know people being
upset in reference to the quality of
this game so overall your thoughts on
the whole red 4 reviews in the
aftermath yeah absolutely thanks for
that setup Cog um I think um when I
first saw redfall I thought it was
intrigued cuz I like some of you guys
was really enamored by prey I love prey
so much it was such a great experience
that and the the way the story was set
up was fantastic so naturally I was
pretty excited by how redfall when was
announced and especially had vampires
and you know vampires in video games has
always been a hit and miss kind of thing
so except for vampire survivors that's
definitely stier addict I don't care
what say should have shot my boy addict
okay you're welcome here
[Laughter]
anytime yeah but getting back to it so
we got the code really late I think it
was like um for you it was like Saturday
for me was Sunday I'm like okay and I
told like the wife and like the kids
like all right Daddy's going to be away
for a bit so I got installed it and I
played it and then um I couldn't get it
out on time and um burgain because it's
just it's it takes a few hours to be I
think it took like me around over 20
hours so the like I played the first
area and I noticed right off the bat
okay the setup was nice okay you get
into the fire station uh you there's
something going on but then the more I
played of it then I got to the loop you
know where you capture the safe houses
you get the skulls you get the nest you
know it just becomes so repetitive and
then um when I first saw my first AI
glitch I was like H okay you know she's
running around
about a oneof thing you know but so like
uh then I noticed it's starting creeping
up more and more and more I'm like God
and but I have to say one thing the
vampire AI they will wreck you like but
the the human AI they're like I don't
know that's what I said yeah yeah it's
it's it's something um I got to
interrupt you for a second cuz I I gotta
say something internally that we you
talk but I got to put it cuz it's so
hilarious so I remember against the cold
y'all so I'm I'm going to do your thing
you know we know we up against the eight
ball you know obviously man is a
professional he's like Co I got you but
I'll do you know probably Impressions or
whatever right so in the beginning right
he go King this man he go yo I don't
know what nobody talking
about I'm like this is like the first
hour right he's like you know this this
this is good I I don't know what so I'm
like oh interesting really this console
this is console
yeah it's on PC so so I cuz remember
what I get I said look yo word on the
street I'm hearing things I don't want
to influence you but word on the street
is I'm hearing things so I'm dying to
know what you thought so the first hour
yo B was lit he's like I don't know what
everybody talking
about so then it was like 30 minutes
later and I saw he's like oh no n i see
what's going on it was just such a funny
thing to read that timeline on our
Discord I had to I had to tell you that
brother I was meaning to tell you I was
like bro it was the funniest
transformation of emotions I seen in a
time but continue I'm sorry for
interrupting continue you're absolutely
right because like yeah cuz I was
enamored at first like yeah this town
going to kill some vampires yes then I
saw that the textur is not loading in
and then just the frame drops and I have
to admit the massive day one patch would
had a lot of issues with where it's
pretty much redownloading the entire
game I had to do it twice but then it
got a little bit better but it was still
wonky and um by the time I was entering
the the second Zone I was just like you
know I I was just like not the face
rushing rushing just you know I just
wanted to finish it and get it over with
and and the best the worst thing about
it is the S some of the side missions
they had a lot of like personal
personalization of the characters like
some people were like going through
grief and they're like telling you to
it's a fetch Quest but it's like but but
like fetch this heirloom for my my dead
mother on grave and there was things
like that there was there was a lot of
potential in there but they just half
asked everything you know it it was like
undercooked and the immersive Sim Els
you can see they wanted like players to
like move around the buildings they had
little entrances here and there and when
you found them they were really exciting
but the the thing about is is there's no
stealth in the game it's either you kill
something or they're just too dump to
notice you and you kill them later
that's all it is and but um I don't know
if I said but I gave it a six out of 10
MH and I feel that for me redfall is a
symptom of Arcane Austin's sort of like
a the last days of of of of zenax when
they were independent they like okay we
need to get into the life service game
so everyone has to do one here's a card
choose everyone choose one and they got
stuck with redfall and that to me feels
like what happened that's the situation
that they got stuck with this game they
had to make it a service game and this
is what they produced because obviously
a as a studio of their caliber should
not be putting out this kind of uh this
kind of game no well said brother me saw
kind of talked about alluded that in our
conversations after Guardians we stff we
had like a little bitty IOP after
talking because I haven't talked to him
in a while but I'm sorry about when you
saying interrup you no no good man yeah
no I mean well said in reference to you
know that's what it felt like right as
far as the you know the be the zenax
days where they were trying to figure
things out pre-acquisition at least
that's what it felt like like to me like
that Fallout M you said it perfect like
that Fallout 76 kind of energy just kind
of throw the wall but s you know let's
talk about it man you know obviously me
and you went to an event and uh saw this
game you know initially and then
obviously we see what's going on now so
what are your thoughts between now then
and the
reception yes so like I said to you
yesterday I had haven't listened to the
L episode of of Duke yet right but I had
hoped that you guys would would talk
about how you feel about the game
through the lens of what we saw when we
went to the preview event and I'm GNA
keep it real with you man like I feel
like we got bambo a little bit I really
do I really do um you know we went to
that event it was a month out from
launch right so maybe it's naive on our
part or whatever but my thinking was I
was going to see at the the the closest
to finished build of that game that we
were going to see right before the
launch my thinking is this is this is
essentially what the game is going to be
um still you know ironing out some bugs
or whatever but this is it right and
what it feels like in hindsight now
after having played the actual game for
a couple of hours not too much time is
that it feels like they took the build
of that game that was running the best
looking the best polished that up as you
would a vertical slice and let us play
that with the anticipation that they
would be able to hit that quality bar in
the final product by the time it
launched and that just did not happen so
essentially what we played was the the
most ideal version of what they wanted
to
release and not indicative of what we
were going to see day one and that to me
that was that's disingenuous because
it's not you know especially that close
to to launch if we were 6 months out
from launch and we got something like
that I I would I would think hey no
there's been a lot of changes to this
before we actually you know it's not
going to be the same thing when when we
go in but a month out again maybe it was
naive on on my part to think that I'm
thinking this is close to done yeah so
yeah what we played and what we talked
about and again I think you know our
impressions are out there right that
that uh that episode of Duke ultimate is
out there for body to listen to I think
you know we we were cautiously
optimistic about the things that we saw
that could be expounded upon that seemed
like they could be exciting in a
four-player multiplayer setting um and
but we were you know were cautious about
you know the the immersive Sim elements
and how they would sort of play out in
an open world where you know same thing
about the Gunplay how that would would
play out and and sort of the looter
shooter aspect of it you know um the
upgrade path what you know how how
significant that would be to the game
play all those things I think we we were
sort of pretty measured about right we
didn't go say oh this the greatest thing
ever um and unfortunately from the
little that I've played which has only
been a couple of hours and it and that
has been marred by crashes like straight
straight to desktop crashes of the game
um is not indicative of that whatsoever
um I'm going to reserve my full judgment
till I play it all because I do want to
play it all just to really see what the
the the fin experiences but what I've
played so
far with the crashes with the you know
with the popping which is crazy
the you're set up you're doing PC 40 40
4090 4090 with an I9 uh the latest I9
what bill that bill you Flex that so
it's I mean it should not be having
problems at all with this and then I
look at the ground it's could have
problems even with the
490 and and and for the
you know the the frame rate generally is
fine like the frame rate F flies but I
still get the popping yeah and I'm
looking at the ground and I'm literally
it's not even quick popping it's the
texture sort of morphing in slowly like
I looked at the floor it's funny CU I I
shout out to Maddie and shout out to
Carrick I I I kind of looked at both of
their reviews and there was one thing
that Carrick was saying that was
perfectly indicative of what I saw he
was looking at a decal on something on
the ground and the decal the texture
wouldn't pop in quickly like you know it
would slowly morph into itself he he
literally timed it and it was a minute
wow a minute for a full texture for 4K
texture to load in wow and so even even
looking at it no no no none of that no
fast SSD no fast SSD I can't with him so
I'm I'mma keep it real from what I
played so far and my thoughts may change
in the long term um this game should not
have been released this game should have
been cancelled and I say canceled for
this watch so I've gotten a little bit
of push back about hey I know you love
immersive s games I know you love the
games that Arcane has made in the
past you have to judge this game on what
it is and not what you want it to be the
problem with and I and I fully agree
with that except for except for the part
where they told us that the immersive
Sim aspects the arcan a shot of the of
of of what the studio is known for we're
going to be a prominent part of this
game it's some something that's going to
be integral to the Gunplay as well like
in how you tackle these these sort of
combat situations the powers and the gun
play are going to be you know work in
Synergy with one another
and we kind of saw it when we first saw
it right it was like well the power
seemed limited and I think they made the
mistake of showing us the entire skill
tree and kind of showing us what the
powers were in their their strongest
form and in their strongest form they
just do things like oh the power lasts
longer or the effect you can jump higher
or stuff you do a double jump it isn't
really they the powers aren't
transformative in a way that gives you
the type of Arsenal that you would
normally see and expect from an Arcane
game well with the type of you know
power set that you end up with um and
it's just super dis pointing so I look
at it and I'm like well you know what I
think I just think from a design ethos
sort of P aspect of it it just it is not
them it's not them I I sincerely feel
that this game came out of a moment
again this this game got started way
before you know the acquisition it was a
moment where Bethesda and Arcane in
particular were looking at okay the
games that we make are well-received
they don't s sell well good point we're
having we're having money issues right
so let's try to make a game that is more
appealing to a more to a general
populace right catching a wave exactly
try to catch a wave after the wave has
passed which is never a good
thing and ultimately try let's see see
if we can integrate the things that
we're known for into this type of game
that may be appealing to a broader
audience and in general and this isn't
Arcane Austin this Arcane Leon was
somewhat successful with death Loop and
I think the success of death Loop is
partially attributed to the fact that
death Loop is still fairly linear like
an Arcane game is as opposed to trying
to you know transpose that that sort of
design sort of philosophy into an open
world I think it can be done and I think
it could be done super well um I look at
something like breath of the wild and
hopefully tears of the Kingdom taking
sort of immersive Sim sensibilities and
throwing them into an open world and
that's exciting to me so my thinking is
hey Arcane the masters of this figuring
out a way to to to a put that into an
open world and B do it in a co-op
setting where everybody powers are
supposed to work in unison in this
really beautiful way and they didn't do
any of that it's not arcany enough the
only thing that I I get that feels like
Arcane is sort of the the the the World
building and the and the design of the
world the characters that feels good
right I I I kind of like that the rest
of it though the gameplay execution when
it comes to the immersive Sim stuff the
stealth is essentially non-existent we
don't even got the stealth kill we don't
have a real stealth animation for for
for for you know for stealth kills you
got you can really only you can really
only enter a you know a building in in
two or three different types ways
specific ways very specific ways um you
just don't have that flexibility and
gameplay that they're known for and then
the the looter shooter part about it is
is when you look at what it's emulating
right you look at a Borderland or maybe
like a Destiny or something things of
that nature it doesn't do it even
remotely as well so it's like what is
this game for so that when I look at
what I've played so far and again my my
thoughts may change in the long term I
look at it I'm like someone somewhere
down the line should have said hey we're
under Microsoft now we can afford to
keep taking the risks of the types of
games that we make without worrying so
much about the monetary sort of uh what
we're going to make back on it and we
could continue to expand upon that
formula that we're the masters of and
they didn't do that um and we got this
so that's why I say so far by what I've
played and what I initially played it
just feels like this is a concept that
should have died somewhere along the
vine and it didn't happen and
unfortunately the consumer has to has to
deal with this and I feel for I feel for
the team because I I just don't again
somebody blame has to be put somewhere
right of course of course at the end of
the day they made this game um but I
just it just feels like no one's heart
was in it to be perfectly honest and
that's weird to say but it just it just
feels like I don't know whose passion
project This was um but again in theory
everything that they have there should
make for a great game you have vampires
right I'm looking at it I'm like okay if
you really really got down about giving
each of these characters a bunch of
different cool powers that worked in
unison with each other the gun playay
was super tight and the the AI was smart
and forced you to think about how
because that's that's the thing about
these games the AI is so intelligent
that it forces you to sort of on the Fly
figure things out and be creative with
your powers exactly and and none of that
is the case I I I killed a vampire that
was out in broad daylight it was it was
in broad daylight and it was floating
above me and I just popped it I I popped
it with a with a rifle twice it dropped
down then it did some cool little
dodging movements or whatever but then I
just spun around and pulled out the
shotgun and killed him two shots and
that that was that and and that was the
most resistance I got from any sort of
any sort of NPC so it all around very
very disappointed um and again I don't I
don't mean to to drag Arcane through the
mud on this one I love that studio I
love what they put out so far this ain't
it y'all this ain't it s I wanted to
comment real quick yeah you're talking
about your your frames and maybe that's
maybe the difference between my my 30
series card and your
$7,000 I I was getting decent frames
like usually above 60 between 60 and 120
but it was inconsistent for me yeah I
was getting like you know one minute I'd
be getting straight 60 the next minute
I'd be 90 next that' be 70 so like I
would prefer a solid 30 over inconsist
we doing it but this is the thing right
and I haven't play there's no in-game
frame cap none none whatsoever insane a
game a modernday game with no option to
cap your
frames is
abur just weird sort of quality of life
things like you said like no option to
cap your frames little things like when
I got multiples of certain weapons right
because is a loot shooter you're going
to get like multiples of every single
weapon and I'm trying to unequip them to
put newer weapons in it doesn't let me
it'll just re-equip to something else
and like and it it won't there's no
option to just unequip everything and
then pick what you want to do God bro
same thing with the just cycling weapons
like you got to go through the whole
cycle the UI with the overlay hey we
want to tell you this tip and the whole
takes up one quarter the screen like
half like almost like Xbox snap from
back in Xbox what and I'm like bro could
you get off the screen like okay I got
it we got the tip like it's certain
things fundamentally I just want to give
slow ball some balls cuz something you
said he said onethird of the skill trees
are dedicated to multiplayer but what if
you don't want or have anyone else to
play with it's like punishing solo
players I did want to get cuz I felt
that way too okay absolutely push solo
too yeah that's me well they did when we
when we saw you don't need a friend yeah
when they saw it they were like okay we
know a lot of the push back is hey this
is an Arcane game you're focusing on his
multiplayer stuff we're going to show
you this game is just as capable as a
single player game as an Arcane
experience and so when I get the push
back about hey love it you know
criticize it for what it is and not what
you want it to be they told me it was
going to be something else yeah you got
to keep setting shots at me bro yeah
yeah no no no but not even it it it
wasn't you it wasn't you no no bro but
no all jokes you were right you were
right when we had a discussion you and
Maddie were harder on it and I was more
hopeful you know on it but look it's not
about me King has been patient I want to
make sure you got your bars off S then
we can get cuz King has been very
patient yes sir hold done yeah but look
red fall you know the the aftermath the
reviews you know Community is very upset
King you know what I'm saying need they
need to hear from the King you know what
I'm saying they need to know what's
going on how's he feeling about this
well I heard Ben say you know I'd rather
play it at a cap 30 oh here we you know
mic came out said got
that we got you cover bro the cap 30
isn't even really it's it's C 30 sure
but it doesn't hit 30
lot I mean King K it it don't it don't
hit that 30 bro hey hey hey it don't hit
that 30 it don't hit it bro I'm sorry I
can't allow this one I I can't allow
this one it does not hit the 30 they
promis over here Mr 7,000 Mr 7,000 we
capped over here
man I know I know your glasses have
vrr they told you temper your
expectations on that PC they said temper
your expectations everywhere they said
they capped over there you you
uncapped you crazy with it be wild with
it he said whatever your PC can do do
it's it's my fault it's my fault it's
your fault you wanted 60 how dare you
this PC go above and
beyond he he said I was running around
that 190 one
time anyway sir okay I I can't sit here
and cap for this game I didn't have
enough time I thought he I have enough
time no no no not at all um when I
turned the game on because I was going
on Xbox uh Xbox 2 plus one yes oh salute
Rand J yeah it was a great show
um and I and I turn this game on I said
there's absolutely no way it's what they
said I went on Colt last
Monday Xbox 2 plus one the next day and
um same thing I gotta hear everybody
that's playing is these NDA dudes that
was playing I got a chance to touch so
and and yes we have some NDA dudes on
our team one is right
here one is right there two are here
M three yeah yeah he got that code I saw
when yeah yeah actually the code it was
weird the code came to me and I'm like
why is the coke come to me exactly that
Co [__] came to you yeah it's like it's
up to you use the for use
the divy it out as you choose
um yo I turned it on and I ain't even
gonna lie
man okay so I picked the the yellow dude
yeah and um I said let me get up he wake
up in the boat now I could not believe
this was
water bro yeah I went to a door and it
had like a broken holes at the top and
what they thought was water coming
down was like a hard if it felt like a
PlayStation one that N64 that hard like
I'm G get to the N64 part in a minute so
we go PlayStation one yeah so I heard
dudes talk about that the graphics was
is that's no
cap that is No Cap no that is no cap at
all I mean you can take the best I guess
Call of Duty 361 remember that take
those those best games and sum of them
out perform this
Duty yo I was walking around the sparse
environment of a a shipwreck right and
it's people littered here and there it's
like okay it's like on this boat there
was only five people
[Laughter]
and all five of them died they had 10
cars all right okay 10 cars five people
I don't know the vampires must have took
everybody El all right now it's in when
I get
downstairs is water again we back to
this water yes yes because we I thought
we conquered water in the 3D
space so we was we was there with it
with the development okay obviously they
didn't get the
memo oh y'all in trouble um I looked at
the water so there was some fake little
narrative to tell you why it looks so
horrible it is frozen because the solar
eclipse has happened the world has
stopped I was like all
right he stupid so I'm I'm going I'm
going in this 360 world but so it's a
360 World with more polygons right
higher
resolution let's get that out the way
not saying better polygons I just said
more okay so I hear people talking D I
have Dolby at most bro you can hear them
so normally they're on the right they're
there over there yeah they above me
they're there yeah if they below me I
hit them down there yeah if they to the
left I hit them over there mhm these
dudes is talking all around me facts I
said where are they at
I can't sneak up on anybody to kill
anybody cuz I don't know where they at
but they talking though and it sound
like they close to me and I keep looking
around like I had the same problem K I
was like Y where they at and I don't
know until they shoot me yes yes and
then you don't even got the Ping to be
like where Direction the bullet coming
from I'm looking for Action so you got
to shoot me for me to get action and I
see you ha then I shoot
you yeah all right so again walking in
the texture Popa this crazy yeah texture
popping is crazy why is it texture
popping I got a
SSD what happened to the velocir texture
velocity
velocity what happened to the mes
shaders and all tell me was it was a lot
of cap it was a
lot time out we G we gonna get to the
real issue the root of the problem we
get to the r of problem what's the of
problem all right so what I think Zen is
MHM is a dude that run his company
MH but he a messy roommate oh man like
you you Phil just trying to get his room
in
order oh we we doing that bad college
roommate oh man Phil Phil got his half
of the room he just got it he was like
yeah okay so this is looking good we
have to push a little things back you
know but we have Forza coming and you
know we dropping a high- five Rush it's
that's a good thing we doing a lot of
things everything's in order and they
like yo yo Todd what you doing over
there dancing by
itself these moves is gonna kill it in
prom I can't he dancing myself in the
mirror and Phil is like um isn't Pete
helping you with those dance moves I
can't you think you can get those dance
moves up to
60 I can't yo sa told you and I hate
this guy for being right so always fire
no matter when these game ship they
broken Bethesda has uh uh a
stigma they have a stink about
them they and you ever had a roommate
that stink that he don't wanted to use
deodorant oh come on he got a stink
about him and Y y'all call it Bethesda y
call it Bethesda isms right y'all be
like y'all be like yeah a little quirks
and quickies well the quarks and the
quickies caugh up to you this is this is
what happens when there's no true
oversight Microsoft has been on their
side of the room and they've been
yelling over there to the other side yo
Pete y'all good yeah
man we good Todd how does it look is
Todd
ready oh right and I know Phil was like
let me go over there and see what's
going on saw a redfall there's no way in
hell nobody saw a redf and was like oh
no this is good to go no way no like y
yo this is it right here we got one what
we gonna do is what we can control we
put out uh
controllers all right controllers
everybody love controllers we G put out
controllers we're gonna have crazy merch
I've never seen so much merch for a game
that is a first party IP first time out
the door I've never seen so many hoodies
jackets shirts fight back we got a com
book Co C did you show it off have you
showed it off let's not let's not
discuss okay I don't know if they wanted
this no no we can we can when you uh leg
when you go look at the uh the designer
lab yeah because um my controller was
messing up so so was like we'll go get
you one of those designer ones I I don't
need nothing like that but I was like
let me go over there and look and I go
look and the first thing they offer to
you is redfall
designs yeah the merch and I was like
yeah I'm going go to Walmart and just
pick up like a regular greaten one but
do you see they they worked on
bamboozling now they they pulled y dudes
out let's get the dudes that rock with
us and we gonna put them all in the room
and we gon give them the highest end
y'all didn't know that I was playing
SSB with all they could possibly have
with nothing else on the operating
system but redfall
they they gave it to y'all and they they
hit it they gave you a controller and
they was like yeah go ahead and play and
have a good time and yeah we're not
going to do what we said the game is
about with the full player you know
interaction we just going to let you
just go out SW they got that voice when
they telling us you GNA touch and then
you know how they do when somebody give
you something they don't really want you
to drive it like you know hey hey you go
and then they take it right
back just go down this street and turn
stuff like this with it yeah yeah you
know you do the test job all right stay
on this this block here don't turn
Circle right back around into the deal
ship parking lot and bring it right back
the best part about this this is car
right and it's a lemon the best part
about this is we have buyer protection
it's called Game Pass oh we doing come
on kid we doing that I don't care the
game suck underscore Ben deleted it yo
Ben deleted it and I'm on my
way all right so I listen
$70 sucks to be you boo boo you could
have did a better deal you could have
took your $15 see this is how pimp moves
happen so we Justified the product we
going justify you we gonna justify you
getting Hoodwink
because you could have said all right
this don't make no sense you have $70
here you have $15 here I'm iffy about
this game cuz I know nothing about it
this is not Castlevania this is not
Metal Gear this is not uh Resident Evil
this is not something that has a
pedigree this is a if okay right and you
didn't know what it was anyway until
they told you you needed to have it you
did not know what it was I thought it
was left for dead type of thing cuz I
love left for dead yeah and then I
thought okay well maybe hopefully it's
better than back for blood because I
didn't like back for blood and hopefully
it's better than evolve I
iol this thing is worse than all of
them all of them all of them combin but
you have
$70 you can take 15 or
$9 go buy a game pass for the month oh
so it's l Timmy for that he bought play
79 Timmy you you you jumped out there
and you was red flagging too
hard how dare he have confidence and
excitement for the product to give it
the money that they they Char it
deserved right give it the $15 you would
not be like this right now well the the
best part about paying $15 to play Red
is that as soon as you delete it you can
play whatever else you want on game you
play you can play Loop hero that look
worse that but better get some Goat
Simulator or something you
know I totally I'm a total Mark for Game
Pass and I rep it all the time but I
can't I can't sit here and say that okay
well it's okay that it was trash thank
you B because you should have just got
it on Game Pass like they presented it
as a premium product from their Studio
Triple A this thing ended the show this
was the just one more thing guys to end
the show I'm not I'm not saying that
it's okay that it's trash don't you
right never don't ever get that part
confused my my message to everyone is Be
Frugal with your dollar the only way
this company will learn that they can't
put trash out is if you don't buy right
you don't and we this is going to apply
later okay you don't
buy they see the number and Ag and Game
Pass you came in the door for Game Pass
see the best part about Game Pass you
came in the door to see that one Chi she
was whack oh what else you got in
here meell you doing here and I'm over
here with this so at no point in time do
you feel slighted because for your $15
you got like what three 400 game so
stop the problem is is it's zenax man I
mean uh um uh
they are dancing to the rhythm of their
own
music and Phil just cleaning up his
side we are finding out how
dysfunctional they
are it's every game like Fallout 76
Fallout um New Vegas these games always
had bugs and problems and y'all old
them y'all thought they was
cute this is what happens when you don't
repand
somebody and this IP comes out on
Microsoft now I gotta say Microsoft was
like we need to return on investment
more than likely and this thing was so
along in the tooth that if we cancel
this game all the devs that worked on
this project don't get their bonuses
don't get paid don't I don't know how
that goes yeah right F but I know some
of their bonuses is tied to the
performance of said game now it doesn't
help if the game comes out and the
performance is trash
right and the game isn't good I because
I saw a
developer went on Twitter and you know
she was basically showing her heart like
she see peers of her Champion that this
game is bad
yeah that's that's what world are we
living in nobody wants a bad game so
yeah the game should have been cancelled
the game should have been deleted
because it's fundamentally a bad game
right from the core it's a bad game
aesthetically it's a bad game
performance Wise It's a bad game it's a
bad game that can't be fixed I don't
believe at any point in time it can be
fixed inside Game Pass I don't care what
patches you do I don't what quests you
do at some point in time that game is g
to just like Fade to Black I I don't
think a sequel comes out for that game
it's one of those just want to get it
out forget it done okay no I he Lord
addict man good to see you brother I
don't know if he's still here see you on
the poping man good to good to hear from
me brother I know we talk about you so
yeah I know this is topic that is
passionate to you so it's was cool to
see you jump in uh you know what's your
your thoughts on on the whole red fall
the aftermath and the reviews and
everything
I think my biggest problem with redfall
is how the coverage was covered um I got
no issue with anyone that does it I
understand it's PR's job that's their
whole thing but I feel like the whole
industry and not just particular this uh
this game could really start to redefine
how PR is done and and it's not anyone's
fault because I feel like what happened
with redfall and where you know where
you guys were talking earlier about you
know S Felt bamboo Boozled over the the
way that the pr was handled it's not a
Bethesda thing it's not an Xbox thing
it's an industry thing and I've spoke
about it multiple times that you know
the industry needs to do a better job at
being more transparent with
products uh you know you know what's you
know what's going to sell better than a
game that you kind of false advertise to
a degree a game that you actually put
time into and you have no problem
showing that time that confidence yeah
and to me that's just the biggest thing
I didn't like it's like you know I'm not
saying that the game that we played
before was night and day difference but
I am saying it's it was dramatically
different and to
me I could handle a game that's
underwhelming all day long I can't
handle a game that I felt like people
were trying to sell me something
else and I think that's the biggest
issue is you know and and plus what does
that do too you know I I'm sure it's
like I said these PR people they're just
trying to they're doing their job but at
the same time you're making you're
making influencers look mad suspect when
they go do these kind of
things and it's just like it's not cool
it's not you know and I feel
like hiding the fact that the game was
30 frames for so long definitely doesn't
make you look good and that's why like
it's very important that I that people
understand this is not a particular
Studio this seems like an industrywide
thing because uh you know shout out to
the people I was reviewing U Jed ey and
I just been I I almost have the review
done but there was just no way I was
getting to it uh this weekend but you
know they lowkey sent me the review code
like mad late and then if when I was
reading the Embargo it was just pretty
much like oh you don't have to worry
about the day one patches they're
already in and I'm like oh so you sent
me these after the day one patches and
and to me that is that's that's an issue
there too it's like you shouldn't be
expecting these reviewers to review
something and not ex and not be honest
about the game and the condition it was
when they reviewed it like what's the
point in having a day one patch that
fixes the majority of the issues when
you could have theoretically just push
the game like two or three weeks and let
them play it the game that's supposed to
be released and not oh we're gonna play
the game for for a week with without the
day one patch and then it's like they
kind of expect you to go back and replay
it yeah but this this is this is the way
the game's going to be launched but
that's not the way I played it yeah
that's and the reviewer played it in a
pre patch state so he's given one
opinion then sometimes you'll see the
community attack the reviewer because
then they'll have the patch version and
they'll be like I have this problem
whatever I'll give you a good example uh
me and smooth play Gears five MH work
just fine no issues but what ended up
happening is they did the
online they did the online connected to
like a Lobby like a connection based
right so we're on here saying yo the
game worked good we had no issues it
looks from our review perspective oh the
game has no issues but then when when
when the servers kicked on and it was
overwhelming it me and smoo got I would
say to the last Act before the game and
uh went live when that game went live we
couldn't connect to each other anymore
we couldn't play the game individually
uh I mean together anymore like I I if I
remember correctly we had to beat that
game individually to to review it wow so
it was only the last act but it's just
like you know this kind of scenario it's
like now what's going to end up
happening is you're gonna have some
people looking mad sus oh why didn't you
talk about these issues because this
wasn't part of the game when we were
playing Fe and and that's why I just I
personally feel like you know once again
the entire industry needs to be more
transparent they need to stop giving
reviewers games that they know for a
fact need a day one patch to to to to uh
to run properly and I feel like that is
the that's the that's the lowest bar
that's there like to be transparent with
your consumers feels like the bare
minimum 60 frames on the on the box art
remember that and it's just you know
even obviously you look at you look at
Red Paul I do feel like the game was
underwhelming uh to a vast majority I
feel like I was nauseous I had uninstall
it like you ask call I was literally
nauseous I had stop I had to beg him to
do like three more levels with me I was
like please I need I need the experience
The Coop please it it was just like this
isn't it man and the sad part about it
is I do
Xbox for the most part I will say
they've been having better reviewed
games and I feel like even though that
they've had better reviewed games a lot
of them have been like you know the um
you know former like double A stuff and
you know some some indie level stuff and
the the sad part about it is all that
all that Goodwill that they've been
building up I feel like releasing your
first big triaa title in this condition
because this is to me to my personal
opinion I enjoy Crackdown more than
redfall cuz at least when I played the
single player I really enjoyed the
single player of Crackdown I didn't
enjoy much redf fall at all and it sucks
because Arcane is one of my OG Studios
that I love and to me you can ask Cog I
was like look I don't I want this game
to succeed just because I don't want
Arcane being turned into a support
Studio because they're stting to lose
faith in the studio or or dissolved yeah
I don't think they would dissolve them
yet I I you know who knows it's just one
of those things it's like at the end of
the day my biggest thing I could take
from Red fall is the industry needs to
be drastically more transparent with us
you uh and and you know again reviewers
I get it when you review something you
need those clicks especially people that
do it full-time but if the industry
won't self-correct itself and the
reviewers continuously review under
these circumstances then at that point
the reviewers are just as f as the
actual people doing it because they can
stand up for it too sure I get it you
might have a couple games that you know
you don't get day uh you don't get out
day one but guess what when the industry
starts having these games these massive
games not having 50 60 reviews and it's
got two or three they're G to start
saying yo what can we do to get these
these reviewers happy I don't think the
reviewers realize how much actual power
they have there's always somebody out
there that
will that's what I'm saying it takes
more than a couple and like the whole
industry got to come together people are
tired of working under weird embargo
lifts and section A has it first and
section b gets it second then everyone's
got to come together and say until you
fix these crazy rules that shouldn't
have been applied I ain't reviewing
nothing from your studio the only reason
why I have to give you a little bit of
push back on that is because everybody
in the space is me me me it's not
anybody see that's the issue yeah but
that's not going to change because me
walks into the store to pay my bills me
make sure that my channel is up and
running me so I'm not gonna lean over
and say hey man are you gonna take a
stand with me not take a stand because
he gotta get his his views up too I'm
not necessarily saying that like we see
this in the uh like not this industry
all the time I mean there's people in
France right now having giant strikes
for retirement age those are unions
there's no and I feel but people go on
strik all the time that's not part of
you you have you see you see massive
amounts of Staff just leaving uh leaving
the thing and going to the pick a line
like to me I get it and it's not an easy
conversation to to not necessarily
because they were a lot of these
reviewers especially the bigger ones
they'll be able to get that money
regardless maybe the views won't be
exactly where it was and it's a hard
thing to ask people to to kiss away a
perfect check but at the same time when
who who's going to make a step first the
industry that has set the boundaries or
the people that keep going against the B
with the boundaries and to me I I don't
see the industry pushing back that much
I don't and and maybe it's going to come
on us the uh the influencers the
podcasters the streamers it's going to
come on us to do something because the
industry why would the industry change
something that's working so well for
them and that's that's my biggest thing
it's like I've always said on this
podcast multiple times over and over
again I am for transparen and actually
being honest that I'm for anything else
and at the same time I can understand
why they do it I do because you know
when you set a system up like that's
been set up it's hard to say yo let's
try something else but at the same time
if they ain't going to do anything about
it and start to put more policies in
place and the end and the reviewers
won't take a stand either then we are we
ever gonna fix it yeah I hear where
you're coming from it's a very very
controversial subject because of the
fact of access and you know it's one of
those things because like King said
there's always going to be someone where
if they're not big enough if you're big
enough to say hey I'm good you know what
I'm saying I'm going to pay for my own
game and I'm not going to let's be
honest this whole thing is about access
let's just it it this is the sad part is
in order to grow in this industry to a
certain degree you do need some form of
indry access unless you have like a huge
amount of money pulling in somewhere
else and and the P to your point the pow
is that being will say hey okay you
decline you feel way there's always
going to be content creative BNC who
they're just trying to get their Channel
off they trying to get make a move and
you know I don't know the answer to it I
don't know you make a tough conversation
and I don't know if there's an answer to
it but I do know one thing the way
things are going now something got to
change regardless the industry
changing or a couple really really big
uh reviewers coming together and saying
they're not messing with that game with
this embargo something's got to change
because we're having more and more of
these incidences all the time like games
are being broken almost left and right
for sure for sure and sometimes
sometimes reviewers say and sometimes
they don't and and it's it's just it's
the transparency on everything it's like
I said don't the people in the chat this
isn't just a one developer one publisher
thing the entire industry does this to a
point yeah look I get my balls off quick
so everybody got got this off um look
this game man I got so much thought it
first of all it's just a major
disappointment it it just it is I'm be
honest this is an embarrassment to me
you know what I'm saying because at the
end of the day this game was delayed a
Year y'all we we we we and keep in mind
Co this is their first $70 game makes
look worse and it's requiring 70 and
here's the thing y'all know me like the
thing that really B I said this on Duke
that really bothered me about this
situation is yo my word mean everything
to me people come to me and say yo coog
what do we think what do you where you
at yo if you're with it you know will
trust it and look I'm not going to sit
there and say that I I did feel slightly
deceived by this situation because look
me saw of Manny went to this thing like
King said it had to be on 490s it had to
be on the best Hall clearly it was not
you know series X but it's just like
what I played was a smooth experience
right what I played it had density right
I'm not going to say it was frame
perfect but it was definitely 60 you
know what I'm saying it was definitely
smooth and I walked away from it like s
said like
okay I'll be consistent they got to fix
this AI cuz I was like some of these
cultists I'm like bro I'm right in your
core of vision how you don't see me you
know what I'm saying some of that I did
like how that the vampires was moving
you know what I'm saying kind of thing
but what I played at that time I said
okay we just got to see how this story
is going to land how this co-op's going
to land and maybe in retrospect looking
back at of it looking back at of it like
this is your C op debut but you only
letting us play the single player you
know what I'm saying looking back at it
now right and L on me the only thing I
will hold is that I should have asked is
the console version going to be
representative of this or at least 60
frames right I should have asked that
but again for all intensive purposes I
thought this is what we're going to be
playing so it didn't even cross my mind
at that time all I was thinking about
okay all the stuff that Harvey was
talking about as far as Studio
development and as far as far as the the
the adversity they went through as far
as getting the game out and then as far
as my main concern was you know the four
player untethered experience from a
cpu's perspective I did them I did
understand that what bothered me is now
fast forward you know mmu we know how
this go right you know generally
companies that feel confident you get
that two week ahead of time Cod so now
we're getting down to the Wi and I'm
just
remember the the week and then you know
adct is firing up on me like adct is
like yo bro way to join that yo and I'm
like yo chill chill check your email
yeah yeah I'm check I'm like I'm
checking it it ain't there right then
I'm starting it some people to the dude
with the 49 there some people are
starting some people are starting to get
it and you know reviewers talk about
themselves like results ain't really
sounding promising all right so my H me
like bro we getting like day or two
before
release I had to literally finally get
it then you know and I'm like all right
not going to not going to complain I'm
not going to sound privileged you know
I'm not going to sound entitled we did
get it okay fine but I'm like look at
the time like we said about the time we
got it we like we ain't going to make
this embargo so all was what's the loget
rule either making Impressions or you do
a tips and tricks and then we just we're
going to miss we don't go extra hard and
slay people to just to make the Embargo
we want the proper experience mm did his
thing salute to you brother you killed
that with the tips and tricks and the
impression and then after embargo you
made the review in a normal time but we
didn't have much time to operate what
now bothers me is the word starts to get
out and I'm like it's soft there's one
thing to be like yo the game is bad
there's another thing to be like yo this
is the worst game I have ever play like
this is functionally broken I'm like and
my mind I'm like yo how how is that like
that's not so now I'm like nah this is
bothering me cuz now remember kog is
taking yo it's a solid experience we
just got that was my initial Impressions
so I call up adct shout out to addict
shout out to DJ I'm like yo get this
series X let's let's get this I need to
see what people are talking about yo I
swear to God this was not the game I
play bro we fired it up I'm like
yo what is this like King and S like
this feels like 360 like I'm in Bend
energy it's so bad like I am laughing
like to the point where you remind me of
remember that gain of Darkness yes yeah
bro it's so bad that I'm looking me and
adct are looking at each other's
characters and their feet are not
matching the terrain yes and they're
like M I'm like yo this is some 360 N64
energy like what is going on this is not
I said ad I swear to God the game
version that we played was way better
than this like what is going on for the
COS so and it's just it's just it's just
a terrible look it it's a terrible look
you know Co did you did you have access
to the whole game or was it just a slice
it was literally a slice of Us coming
out of the firehouse from the beginning
right it was the slice before the boat I
mean after excuse me after the boat
after the boat was the slice I still
don't know how some of those problems
were fixed but that I mean that gives
you some excuse that they didn't you
weren't playing the whole game they had
perfected a p
here's the part that was scary for the
console me and AD and DJ we're we're
running mad blocks I'm not I'm hearing
voices and not seeing no enemies I'm
going mad but I see one person so I'm
like the game that I played was DSE so
you remember there as soon as you come
out the firehouse you you go down those
that little ramp steps into the park
there was like the blue area the gate
there vampires there was cultist moving
back and forth there was enemy density
like I'm just like yo what is this I I
felt so bad at the console exper I'm
like yo this is not it this is not fish
yeah like bro like it was different so
that's the part you know what I'm saying
I will stand on my square that at least
I did call out she look like her IG
picture yeah she did not look like her
IG picture at all so that's my thing and
it's just like you know the AI ends up
being worse and and look I'm not going
to run to Too Deep with it but it's just
like to me it's kind of what y'all said
earlier like this felt like
pre-acquisition Bethesda you know what
I'm saying this felt like yo we're going
to try to catch a wave we need to do
something and at some point who stamped
finish
who who stamp finish and said this is a
goal this is unacceptable and that to me
is indicative of the pipeline at some
point I understand and we're going to
get into you know obviously just going
to transition into the FI thing and
we'll get into but it's like at some
point there has to be the quality
control pipeline they need a whole
police
police what happened to each one each
one though what happened to the to the
week once once every 3 months we have
group meetings and we exchanged
technology between who wasn't who was uh
red FS partner and we're going to get to
that we're going to get to that but this
is clearly a problem with
pre-acquisition projects of a company
that now has been acquired this pipeline
has to be because this is unacceptable
and the Xbox fan base you're charging
$70 for this game I don't want to hear
about oh it's going to go on game pad
and then we going to fix it later that
sets a dangerous precedent and a
dangerous perception on Optics that you
could just throw something in and okay
we'll deal with it later and back to the
store yeah Xbox deserves better Xbox
deserve better so that's it you know you
deserve better yeah absolutely so that's
all I want to say we gonna get into the
meat of this how did it feel feel being
catfish I me bro not not fun bro not fun
it hurt because yo you know what they
sound like Ben remember that guy it was
in the papers that he sued his wife uh
he got married to her and then he woke
up the next morning she ain't have the
makeup and all that
stuff he turned over like who the hell
is in my house he called the police oh
man I I know how much you enjoy your
your merch and your special edition so I
got to know how much you'd buy for
redfall before the game come out
actually I'm I'm I'm I'm good I'm good I
didn't go in on anything I I do have a
shirt wow so even you had doubts what
you're saying I did let us all you had
doubts you wouldn't by the merch you
knew it was going to be I'm just yeah
you know cuz you know I'm going to come
on Define the Duke with the shirt if I
feeling if I'm all the way in you know
you going to see that shirt that week my
listen my Starfield jacket just came I'm
I'm going in I'm hoping you know I got
the bro I got I got the Starfield bubble
Goose I'm ready in the summertime but
look now your okay your in your defense
yes I was I was a little gunshot let me
see but I but it was like you Ben it was
one of them Jo I thought I was going to
like this is me and homies players and
some aspects of it you can see that they
it's a part of a game there when you
going through the door through the
vampire nest and but it's just so simple
game to first you know what I'm saying
and and the reason being you know this
is a very highly anticipated game we
know how important this is to the Xbox
ecosystem exclusive that we've been
hearing for so long and we've got little
tidbits here in there but we haven't
gotten the meat and this supposed to be
the meat and potatoes so again I'm gonna
give it back to you g because I know
your time is limited as far as um you
know how are you feeling about the
Starfield direct what are your
predictions
there uh me I don't know that it's a
prediction to say that we're going to
find out some of the basic frame rate
stuff because Phil said that's that's
coming I think they need to answer some
questions about Starfield mainly what
does the Action level gameplay look like
what does the narrative gameplay look
they've got some gameplay stuff to
answer we've seen some gameplay there
but like what's going to make Starfield
special in the game playay category
because because uh not too long ago we
were comparing it to No Man's sky right
and that's not that's an Optics thing
right that's not ingenuous of the of the
actual uh experience at least I don't
think it is so I think what what we're
going to see is a Bethesda that's
realizing perhaps the responsibility
they now have as a first party studio
right because they've had a win and
they've had a loss this year and
Bethesda is delivering the 2023 content
uh that people are looking at
so I think the responsibility on
Bethesda now is much higher than perhaps
they realized and so they're bringing
their aame for Starfield uh willing to
bet you see not just a controller
willing to bet you get a special edition
console uh I think you're GNA see some
deep dive questions answered and I'm I'm
there for it right like I'm there for it
and I hope that it's a different energy
than the actual showcase proper right I
want to see the distinctive difference
between the two too that's important so
no doubt dirt gregy I don't know I never
got a chance to talk to you dirt about
how you feel about Starfield overall
never knew your excitement or not I
don't know if you but the guy like that
in that sense but how are you feeling
about the Starfield direct coming in
with your predictions there well first
off I will say you know how important
this game is because they are having a
30 minute direct dedicated to this one
game sir um it's super important um like
go said though I I believe Bethesda
knows how important this game is and and
they're under Xbox now that comes with
an extra level of scrutiny they probably
didn't have before EXT bit of
eyes us right that they didn't have
before you know before they was
multiplatform but now they're only
they're on the Xbox so people going to
look at them a little bit different and
judge them a little bit more stricter
than they would have previously so I
believe they uh know how important it is
obviously Phil Spencer Knows and I think
this game is is huge for for Xbox this
is bethel's First new YP since when I H
what the 90s I don't even know um you
know and their their games are very
popular from the fallouts to the Elder
scoll so this game uh it it means a lot
I'm sure Xbox knows that but theza
definitely knows that and um having a
direct means they're they're ready to
show this game off it also means in my
eyes is it probably won't get another
delay um I do believe they will have
some Hardware like we already saw the
controller man maybe some headphones
maybe a console like goost said I think
little series ass little little little
man in thing okay okay yeah I mean I
mean you know just just my prediction
but uh yeah it's it's it's going to be a
lot of fun man because I believe
Starfield will be a great game and I'm
looking forward to it no doubt no doubt
I see y'all avoiding the frame talk but
we going to move on both yeah
I'm okay
say nothing about them frames you want
you want to clarify what you think the
frames might be before I move on I think
it's 30 okay I think it's 30 and I'm say
right now uh smooth 30 is better than an
inconsistent janky 60 um if if if it
plays smooth we don't get to complain I
don't think okay uh okay but that is
that's not to say I don't want it 60
that's should be not that you against
the performance that sounds like someone
who just came off of performance mode on
Star Wars Jedi
Survivor uh Survivor can I pause on
Survivor if they had waited a week till
Star Wars week May 4th that patch would
have been golden why didn't they do that
is such a strange thing because within a
week it was fixed yeah what a weird
weird pocket wants what the pocket wants
continue go through that I do have to
ask dirt about the frames yeah so I I I
think it's 30 smooth 30 um but but let
it be smooth um don't promise the world
don't Market it don't Market it it's not
I don't so can we can we put 30 frames
on the screen and say 30 y'all what you
can do is is give me a box that has a
sticker that covers up to 60
frames GH
no are you it's too soon ghost I it's
too soon I recovering from that was
insulting fair enough fair enough dirt
where are we at with this frames you
know honestly um I can obviously be
wrong just a prediction but I think it
will have a 60 FPS
mode I think it will have a 60 FPS mode
uh but I think you know maybe the
resolution dip to on the X to 1080p on S
720 okay so we we don't worri about we
worried about the resolu long as it get
there listen that's people say right you
don't care about resolution just give me
a solid 60 they of the Kingdom Vaseline
mode right shut up can't I don't I don't
now I don't know if it'll be a lock 60
but I think it will be a a qu 60 FPS mod
at 720 it better be locked it that door
better be locked
shut if they if they say it and they
can't deliver it they're going to get
dragged so under promise on frames yeah
well Phil said it was kind of funny and
shout out to Paris Lily in the chat um
he they did say that the frame rate will
be addressed we will know he did say
that so that is interesting that is let
me get the plume he's been patient man
so how we feeling about I don't know
what's your connection to Starfield or
not you know how you feeling about it
how what's your predictions on the
direct and of course the frames question
yeah no I'm I'm extremely hyped for it I
mean I was going through this year and
I'm thinking the amount of time of game
that's going to be taken up by Zelda and
then Starfield this year is going to be
like 50% of all my gaming so I'm I'm
extremely excited for it and like DT
said they put a a 30 minute show just
for this game this is it this is like
essentially everything is this is Xbox
this year this is the biggest thing that
they know is going to bring in the most
traffic so it's a huge show I I think
they're going to go into deeper Dives of
like the entire planetary system you
know like the Thousand planets um get
the mod Community excited and all the
stuff they're going to be able to do I
think we're going to I I agree there's
going to be some Hardware announcements
like the control we've already seen the
leaks so that's definitely going to be
there there's a headset we saw um I
think I don't know if they're going to
do console a console just because we've
been hearing about like the hardware
issues they're still having so I don't
know how feasible it is to get a bunch
of Starfield special editions unless
they're all just sitting in a warehouse
waiting for this game to come out but I
think we're GNA get a special edition of
the game I don't know if you guys saw
that previous leak of like the
Smartwatch I feel like that's going to
be something that comes yes Mr MADD put
me on to that yep so I think that's
pretty cool that to me is like an
amazing special edition if I can replace
this crappy
thing um I think we'll also see like one
of the biggest complaints from the first
Gameplay trailer they showed was some of
the combat where like enemies weren't
reacting to getting shot so I think
we'll see all of that polished out kind
of like what we saw with Halo infinite
with their first trailer and then the
second trailer was a lot more polished I
need that com and yeah and um
yeah I think it's going to be I think
it's going to be just an amazing game
and I'm G to go with 60 FPS frame
rates he was confident he's conf he said
that's strong that's I've been I've been
saying 60 from the beginning and I'm not
going to change my stance on so I'm
staying I'm going die on that hill I'll
die Hill give me confidence give me I
want to know why you standing on it
let's go I I just think like what's a
first- person shooter I think they know
they saw first of all the drawbacks and
like the outrage about red fall you know
Phil Spencer was on the phone with Todd
Howard right away he did say he over
there he said he sent team you got that
ready you got the at least a mode
that'll like maybe unlock but I think
like they're aiming for 60 FPS and I
don't know I just feel like they're they
have to do it I mean they got to just
lower that resolution get that frame
rate off they got to do it it's a first-
person shooter no matter what people say
say like there will be anger if there
isn't 60 FPS there even though it's it's
a Bethesda RPG and people are going to
play the hell out of it there will be
there's 60 FPS I don't think they want
that again so all right he feels it in
his
plumes you C
that I could I could resist I was
thinking about but moving on moving on I
don't know if add add is probably's
start to go but um I was curious my
brother loves Starfield man I wanted his
opinion on this one hopefully I get it
when he comes back but Lord s fellow
bethesdan fellow selfish single player
rest in RPG immerse yourself for hours
don't talk to us for days yeah leave me
alone how are we feeling coming into the
Starfield direct what's your predictions
and how you feel about them frames what
a frame situation to me uh listen I
think King mentioned this a couple weeks
back but it it's really time to start
showing all of these things that they
Xbox series X was touted was touting the
FSR and all of these things the sort of
variable
resolution velocity AR talk velocity
architect all that stuff Implement
Implement all of the special SCE you
want all the sauce you want the esram
all it all of it all of it all use the
cloud whatever we we want to compute
power from the cloud on this we want all
the res Jason we want all the resources
we want all the resources
all this kid we want all the tools we
need we need the tools off you better
the tool all the tools all the libraries
all of
it um this game has to have a
performance mode it really does it needs
to be it needs to show that it can be
done there and do what you need to do in
terms of variable resolution whatever
you need to do get that mode in there
and then of course give people their
their 4K 30 uh resolution and of course
obviously the series s is going to be
Pro more than likely I would I mean it
would be amazing if they could figure
out way to get a super you know whatever
480p
performance oh my God par said 540p at
120 frames let's go let's do it um but
that's to me that is that's important
that's important I know it's not
important to Todd per se but I think you
just have to again narratives you have
to look at what is going to make the
base excited and what is going to make
the base angry and kind of you have to I
feel sometimes when especially when you
talk about uh presentations of this
magnitude you really do need to come out
there and show um so that would be great
and I and I hope that that is the case
um I'll be playing on the PC so I don't
you b r I'm not I'm not just not I'm not
not even dealing with this console
nonsense no no no um but I really do
think that it's time you over there I
really do think that it's time for all
of this console stuff that we heard from
the beginning of the generation to
really come to fruition and start to
start seeing it in these games um in
terms of what the has to show we've seen
a lot of the game already right we have
um but I really do want to see console
gameplay right console gaml so we can't
we can't pay we can't say captured on PC
and we can't get away with that listen
man as someone who was recently at a red
for
man but you don't want to see the 49 you
don't want to see what the 49 could do
or the see that at home I'll see that at
home the the this is this is for the
Xbox okay okay fa you don't have to
include the rest of the ecosystem please
the Xbox you want an honest
representation of what Xbox is going to
get what Xbox is going to get I think
that's very important so it has to be it
has to be nice nice it has to be console
gameplay um they have to show the
hardcore RPG guys how much of a hardcore
RPG this is right and it has to be in
such a way that it's is brief enough
that it doesn't bore the C more Casual
Gamer because you also have to show the
game in a more casual action oriented
like that's that's not going to turn
away the guy that's like what what do
you mean this some in-depth a lot of
menus kind of you know RPG that may turn
some people off so I think what's great
about this game and Bethesda games in
general they do have that very sort of
action oriented aspect that it's that's
amazing when to play uh well it's gotten
gradually better to play over the years
yeah I want I want to see if they how
they improve that dialogue system you
know back in the old days like you know
the old Fallout games you can literally
not fight the last boss and just talk
him like you can you can talk no Jutsu
to him and get him not to lower his
guard but it just felt like in Fallout 4
it's like dud it don't matter what you
say I'm I'm pulling up I'm pulling up
right and then that's the thing because
those old games and again the immersive
Sim lover and me loves the fact that you
could do you can get around all that
stuff so my hope is that they do go back
to that so it has to show on a spectacle
level it has to show and on a technical
level it has to show and and show that
again because a lot of you the hardcore
RPG guys want this to be a hardcore RPG
um so and I do think I do think Todd
knows that and I think that's what we're
going to get um we may be disappointed
in terms of the frame rate stuff I don't
know but um I think the game is going to
show well and I'm excited to see it no
doubt no doubt Lord addict my fellow
Bethesda brother what's your feelings
what's your predictions about this just
the Starfield direct portion and and uh
what's your prediction on the frame rate
I want to spend that whole 45 30 minutes
just showing gameplay I don't want to
see Tod har no controller I want to see
no jacket it's like you come out there
like you do that you do that off the
stage you know you you could play the
game off the stage I don't want here's
the thing we've seen too many where
people up there playing stuff and you
get the game and it ain't nothing like
that like it's I don't I don't want one
of those scenarios where they're just
pretending to play the game oh look at
that like no like like you you better
show me I want like one of those things
where I touch like press the start press
up down eight times let me make sure
they say pre-recorded like it's just
like look I I want them to show us that
this game is actually functioning I want
them to be very transparent on whether
or not this game's going to be 60 on the
series X you know if it's not just just
tell me I'm playing on PC now hour like
it's just one of those things where it's
like you need 30 minutes of game play is
unrealistic I mean it is unrealistic but
guess what he asked me he didn't ask you
he asked me
oh fair enough let's go the show is
about to start we got 32 seconds the
countdown is crazy here we go I ain't
going to lie man we here we go here we
go here we
go gam playground
games let's do it what's this their
disproportionately Haring
gically massive weapons I show
you ring up oh
hell you might as well wrap that
PlayStation up in the do cuz it's
over it down y me Spiderman look like a
kid toy yeah this ain't game playay I'm
waiting to see game playay look like
game play to me baby and I saw Spiderman
sliding down the wall
let's go
go yeah Xbox game studi Xbox game studi
present that's one here's
two know what game is hell no it's
called a surp it's called a surprise
surprise you seen it
no sou sou of midnight Midnight new
title new title been announced you you
want to know what they working on
they're working on your
demise stop
how on
Su oh man do it came for some gam playay
not gameplay walk
through with theall answer could you
imagine Hades with uh four players 33
players 33 player co-op I guess the
cloud do work not like that
[Music]
SSD oh man what's this water looking
shimmery wait Xbox game
presents hey
Spiderman J dub this is what they paid
for right 5 years ago right King you
know what the best part about this is
Game Pass Game
Pass everybody's dead right now let's go
H necromancing at his fin look at that
that Xbox game studios was another one
another one hey
Spiderman where you at look look she got
smoke she got smoked from the
mouth you might as well
stop Horizon who they going for the kill
Game Pass no I'm not saying that it
don't look good I'm just saying it's
like oh hold on Xbox game studios
presents hold on we out here another one
let him cook son let him cook they got
30 Studios oh here we
go right before Spider-Man punch
Spider-Man in his mouth look at that car
look at that car new look at the car
Lani bring me to defibrillator we got to
revive these PlayStation people let's
see that race tracing not impressed no I
just want y'all to know October 10th
what I said this is a okay show so far
for Xbox event I ain't going lie I get
props that and man this is if you would
have pray to make this show don't lie
don't lie don't lie man come on man that
show was
nasty hold on Bethesda what's this this
game look ridiculous that looks
ridiculous gam oh you be out space with
your walking hold the
line what the is this road simulator you
want to know how the sewage systems work
we got a game for you
game out n ex out Microsoft looking
really brand new out here Lani give me
that great Pon we
eating's G anywhere else makes you
wonder where I
will buing very steam punkish we control
the future there no Sony
in remember this is how it happened
Clockwork
Revolution so um yeah Xbox showcase the
after bath you know what I'm saying and
um you know got a chance obviously it's
good to be with y'all all together you
know obviously you guys are here front
lines holding it down live reactions
being clipped every we're me and addict
out there in the field in the actual
building and you know so it was a little
different all of us not being together
but now that we reuniting how we feeling
you know I got a couple questions for
yall like how are we feeling now that
the dust has settled you know about the
Showcase I don't know if you got a
chance to look back at it you know in
its entirety and um think the other
things I have like okay what you think
could have been improved or not improved
and another thing I kind of want to hit
separately is I want to hit Starfield
direct separately so let's just talk
about the Showcase outside of Starfield
now that the dust is settled how we
feeling start you Lord
adct uh the overall showcase I thought
it was it was a solid show you know
people you could nitpick it all but I
think for the most part Xbox did show
look we working on these Studios these
is what they're doing I will say that in
terms if you still want proof that some
of these studios are delivering the type
of experiences or is the money that
Microsoft having going to actually
Elevate some of these these developers
that is still in the air but I will say
like you see Starfield a lot of the main
production of that game was done under
Xbox so it's just you know 2021
Starfield probably was going to come out
but they gave them till 2022 and then
they gave them an additional like year
up until
2023 so you know you can make a lot of
assumptions you can go left or right
when it comes to a lot of things but you
can clearly see that Microsoft is
funneling money funneling talent and
more importantly funneling time to these
Studios look at wasteline three they put
a lot of different content in there that
wasn't going to be in the base game they
gave them time uh psychon
too the majority of those bosses weren't
in the game if not any of those bosses
were in the game but guess what because
of the time and money Microsoft was
funneling through that studio they gave
uh they were able to make the game
better there's been very few incidences
where you can argue to say that it's not
been that way across the board sure some
studios You could argue mismanagement
but guess what when you got 23 25 30 50
60 kids some of the they going to
Rebel no doubt no doubt what I was going
to say for you ad cuz I know your time's
limited oh want to try to get as much
bars from you as possible what games
again out we're going to keep Starfield
direct separate what games had you the
excited the
most I would say Starfield
Fable um that that Clockwork clock
retion that looks really good too I
don't know why but that 33 game 33
morles that that game would had me
pretty hyped I actually might reach out
to them try to get an interview on the
on the Channel with them Co-op Hades
light yeah it's just like
look that's the best part about this
sure some games res Resolute with me
less than others but I can't say nothing
on that show was less appealing than
other stuff sure there's stuff I was
more excited about but when you're
looking at you know they had solid
experiences and solid showings of these
games there you know we we talked about
you know people don't necessarily care
if Indies are in in in these show one
Lord It's one Lord that they disagree
here they they they just the leadest
people people generally want to see
Indies that are appealing to that
individual person and you know City
skylines too very popular game it's
there that 33 game you know interesting
sure it's not known but it's interesting
it's there you know going to the
PlayStation thing they had three Indie
Games dedicated a cat game to cat you
know for the most part
maybe stray kicked off so well they
backed up the truck to some of these
Indie developers when it come to cat
related experiences it's like Xbox did
what they were what I wanted them to do
okay here's some of the and what's funny
is they did the 12mon thing and they
didn't say it like if you really think
about it clock besides clock yeah and
Fable every game coming out in 12 months
yeah in way that is correct lasting from
you um anything that you would have
improved could have improved Mich show
you think um I do think in the middle it
started drying out a little bit like um
it just got to the point where I I think
that the biggest criticism I can give is
listen to the community there's no way
people that was in charge of that
particular showcase thought showing
hellblade without combat was going to go
over well for them to me and maybe you
guys disagree I feel like it would have
been better to just not show hellblade
day interesting if they were going to
show another CG of the thing that we
know right the biggest thing we know
about hellblade is this going to look
good and she's crazy yeah psychosis is
is real psychosis and guess
what that's all we still
know it's just that that that's my
that's one of my good critiques I can
give them another big critique I can
give them is I know they did that star
Phil direct but I felt like it could
have the pacing could have a little bit
different like you know Phil should have
came up there said you know this is the
show that we want to give you guys blah
blah blah however he him and PR decide
to to spin it but we have one more game
to show you before we get to the
Starfield one and then they
show Clark uh Clockwork
Revolution CL Clockwork like I I feel
you this is now we we we we did pick it
for Perfection right but I know what you
said right it's like we be and you in
the theater next to each other the one
more game ended up becoming Starfield
and we we going to get into Starfield H
amazing that was which ended up being
fine but me and you both agreed that if
like qu Clockwork Revolution was so
impressive they could have laid that as
the here's the last one more game then
you end with Clockwork Revolution then
you put the timer up and then King this
be a long time like two minutes and you
got to think too we sat there for an
hour I think like an hour and 10 15
minutes or something like
that it would have been easy just to
give like a another five minute
countdown give people enough time to go
use the bathroom or something and then
go into the starf or they could have
just went straight from that one more
thing to star field but I didn't like
the fact that they kind of got rid of
the one more thing cuz that's that's
always something that we look forward to
because they've done it with Fable
theyve done it with redfall they've done
it with Starfield well not them
particularly Bethesda did it with
Starfield they might have did Elder
Scrolls I can't remember particular that
year but they they have done so many
yeah we got one more game for you and to
me they kind of like got rid of that
magic and all it could have been kept
intact if Phil just came out there and
said this is what we have to look
forward to but before we go and start
the Starfield direct we have one more
game to show you I understand I
understand your nitpick I I I I
definitely see where you're coming from
based on tradition and maybe part of it
was they were just so excited that maybe
they knew they had something with
Starfield that it was just like we going
B but I hear where you going from let's
get let's get sof you know now that the
dust has settled you know what's your
feeling how you feeling about the
Showcase and then what was the things
you were most excited for
I mean it's it's still a nine for me
right last week I was kind of hovering
eight five 8.59 it's definitely a nine
for me um and I'm difficult to please
when it comes to them right what
solidified this it's just the fact that
they did exactly what I needed them to
do wanted them to do was there so many
first party stuff that you've talked
about already right we saw some stuff
that we kind of because of because of
our proximity to the industry we you
know certain things leak and things like
that and and you kind of have an idea
certain things are coming but sometimes
that comes to fruition sometimes it
doesn't right so for me the thing that
that that popped crazy was Sega in the
building Sega being in the building big
time it come on I say it as a joke no we
Sega kids I want it to happen it's just
it's traditionally not been a thing that
and which is funny because again we
always saw Xbox as the surrogate Sega
right for whatever reason obviously we
saw what happened during the Xbox one
generation that relationship seemed like
it distanced and then now it's being
reforged again and to see the presence
there with not only the new like a
dragon right and ich Bond's
buns getting M
demonetized getting everybody
demonetized out here showing his buns um
but to show Persona 3 remake for the
first time on this stage to show tactics
for the first time on this stage and
then to announce a new IP from the
creators of persona on this stage is
huge it is huge is it foreshadowing sir
it absolutely could be but I'm not
giving that up as someone King who holds
the line until the very last I'm I'm
just listen I I got to I got to throw my
little needles in do not begrudge me
hold I love what you doing I love I
respect it I respect the very last day I
got to say I got it I got to say it
ain't looking good for
me it is only it is only if my man Jim
Ryan had the foresight had the foresight
to have the exclusive bag before the
relationship so there's nothing about be
able to do about it up not to stop
snitching not toit man ain't gonna
snitch on that one
right so I don't know I don't know if
that happened but this is a good look
this is a good look this is Xbox needed
this and to see that love um I think you
know if sega's going to go to anybody I
would love to see them with Xbox if
that's going to happen at all they ain't
going to nobody they damn sure ain't
going to uh
Sony I'm not going to my
Killers but let me see what else what
else impressed me obviously seeing Fable
for the first time like I just had when
I saw it I was like oh addict I like oh
addict I've never felt happier yeah for
someone else for some bro let me tell
you king
he scared me ad scared me because we're
in the theater you pass out but he
didn't react so he's just he's just
Frozen watching so in my mind I'm like
he's so critical and this is beloved if
the and I'm sitting there remember I'm
the Fable casual I like it I'm not as
hardcore as him with it I played it I
remember it but I was more in the Halo
and other things during the OG days of
of what but I do like it cuz the level
of fornication yeah the Savage do so I'm
looking at it and I'm like okay this
looking
really yeah and I'm looking at him and
then he ain't saying nothing so I tap
him and I'm like we good like you know
this is his baby he's said oh no we good
I said oh I said I it is pleaseed let's
go Contin he he was just in such
shock but they they they nailed they
nailed the tone they nailed the comedy
they nailed what I would love to see
from the combat right just in seeing
those those parts we don't know how much
gameplay that actually is Al that is an
engine and that is can very easily be
gameplay um I just love where it seems
like they have a really really good idea
of what they want to do with this IP and
make it their own while still having
reverence for the tone of it and what it
was in the past right it's a fine line
to draw it's it's difficult you think
about you know Studios that have taken
over IP you look at the 3 43s or
whatever it's not easy to do yeah um so
and for them their first time out they
they tasked with rebooting the whole
damn thing that's a huge responsibility
it's a huge responsibility I think so
far so good everything looks great real
quick did did they say 2024 yeah tell me
yeah oh they didn't say 2024 I thought
they did and M it was nothing but Sol
did you see it it is so impressive
looking that you have people questioning
whether or not they had combat and
gameplay in it and you got the devs
responding on Twitter with the the time
when she threw the Fireball and when
they did the sword class cuz they what
they did is they clipped it in really
quick it was like a quick flash throw
the Fireball and so it all looked very
cinematic right so they were like it is
the ultimate flattery for us when people
tell us this is not gameplay like I
built the combat se he put the clip up I
was like yo that is impressive I sorry
to interrupt but I did want to say that
so that um and we'll talk about
Starfield separately so beyond that
obviously um Clockwork
Revolution CL Revolution um I I was one
of the first ones I think right on the
show live I was like has some it has
some Bioshock energy and I was like okay
and I didn't realize how close to that
Bioshock uh infinite sort of trailer
that was the the trailer and the funny
thing is that trailer a lot of stuff in
that trailer the Bioshock one ultimately
did not come to the game in that form
right it wasn't that so they they kind
of idea wise they were kind of on the
same wavelength but the the momentto
moment gamep playay was what this game
is supposed to be it's going to be very
distinct from what Bioshock is first of
all it's still an RPG right so they're
gonna stick to their root and that but
is an RPG with the Fidelity of a third
person sort of Bethesda Style game um I
am super interested to see how they pull
this off the time uh mechanic seems uh
something super interesting again I'm
interested to see how they pull that off
in game but I like the fact that in
Exile is getting that shine man they're
getting it you know because sometimes no
matter how great the games that they
make if they make a certain type of game
and in a certain pocket and with for
them you know the isometric RPG kind of
crpg style of game they may be great
you're not going to get as many eyes on
it with this you're G to get the eyes on
it that's going to allow people to see
how great they are right and and then
gravitate to their other stuff so I love
that and finally got to interrupt one
more time um and it got to shout both of
y'all out that that that was holding
down for us in Exile tweet did ILP they
love you and King's reaction to how
impressed you were so to see them show
and they're very active on social media
and I agree to see them show out with a
budget and the way like they were
looking to see how people um received it
so shout out to y'all cuz they however
y'all reacted when that came up they
were like shout out to IOP like they
they lived for that cuz they were really
proud of you could tell what they what
they put out but continue so yeah and
finally about there was other quick
things like I I I like seeing Star Wars
there we'll talk about that in the
Ubisoft in the context of Ubisoft um
obviously Capcom showing out what a
brand new IP was awesome too um they
kind of I thought it was Anie Musa at
first and then it wasn't it wasn't but
again was a great fake out though yeah
definitely a great fake out and the fact
again brand new IP from Capcom being
showcased coming to Game Pass day one
right fantastic but for me and this one
this one I I was surprised to to the
some of the reaction online was the AOW
cuz I was I saw that rout I was like yes
let's go and then afterwards when I
heard it was like it's a smaller game
and it's it it's not trying to be Skyrim
esin scope like I'm I'm Gucci
everybody's been asking for oh they said
we GNA do us we're not going to try what
we do what we do this is the thing about
it right and and this is and I'll go
quickly into one of my worries still for
for Starfield is that the stuff that is
the stuff that it is sort of preann and
stuff like that again are we going going
to have that wide ocean 2 Ines deep when
it comes to depth of gameplay and no
specific scenarios right not the not the
crafted scenarios but the other stuff
right why would you want them to make an
entire game mimicking that when their
thing is depth of Storytelling
characters tightly knit story have them
just keep doing that in different worlds
infinite possibilities with the story
where you can completely change the
outcome of of stuff because of of that
yeah absolutely right exactly and to and
to to to do a story in the pillars World
which is already very lore rich and to
do another story in that world that that
that kind of removes you from the
previous two pillars games I think it's
great I think this is what they do best
they take formulas and they can kind of
parse it down into something smaller
that is a lot more detailed and for me
personally as somebody who wants more of
that in my nextg games where worlds feel
more alive character interactions feel
more lively they're better positioned to
do do something like that in a smaller
scope game so I'm excited for AOW I'm
excited for what I saw I don't need it
to be Skyrim part two I don't need it to
be that so overall they got that nine
for me man they really did it I get my
only gripe yeah would be the same as
what everybody else yeah I didn't need
to see hellblade again if you didn't
show me that fight because you know
listen they they need to up for it to
really have that hash one just one sort
of standing it needs to improve on that
moment to moment uh Combat gameplay
because the inevitable sort of
comparisons are going to be made to
other games in that vein especially with
this game looking as good as it does
right and narratively being as strong as
we expect it to be so we we need that
right so I I hope we get that the game
awards or something like that or maybe
even games come who knows um so that and
then the one more thing thing yes also I
said they could have just and This Is Me
Being Greedy yeah this is now we
striving for Perfection right I just one
more thing cuz we already knew you're
going to give us an hour of Starfield
give us just and it does it it could be
five years out six I don't care just
give me a logo so people go crazy and
crying and whatever and that would have
really been the icing on the cake but
again they they were fine they were fine
um very impressed with this now now the
hard part execution execution absolutely
absolutely King you are the whole the
line movement you know you were in the
you know you were in live in the mix so
now that the dust is settled you know
we'll get to Star later but like how we
feeling about the Showcase you know
how's you feeling about what was the
games that had you most excited
specifically um we have a thousand
people watching and 500 likes oh we
these likes up get these likes up y get
the likes the the only reason why I'm
asking you for the likes and and likes I
hope it doesn't take anything from you I
hope when you push the like button you
don't lose no lik but that don't happen
to you yeah I I think and and I think
this is true that when you hit the like
button you save the uh Puerto Rican
platypus pu r with
platypus R got to save all the Platypus
around the
worldy to say we got
man that's manap that's manap job we're
gonna save the African platypus when you
share it out but um let's let's let's
let's do that because it helps us in
algorithm facts um and I'm just learning
about
it all right so the last Xbox show we
was like oh that's the great best format
that they got they need to keep that yes
they listen yeah I believe this is
anamax I believe Aaron Greenberg and a
marketing team is the best at dealing
with fan toofan
contact on the ground his team has no
equal right not even Bethesda with their
Bethesda shows has that level of contact
with their with their fan base the way
that they do they the way that Microsoft
implements it is is um so intimate M so
casual so family oriented that it's hard
to quantify right uh and Bethesda would
do a show their shows were like ringland
brothers and balling belly circus it was
the greatest show on Earth nothing bad
Beth show person because I got a
question to you right being that you was
at FanFest this year and I thought it
was going to be in his limited capacity
did you feel that they put on The
Greatest Show on Earth but kept it still
familyfriendly close contact uh IM did
you feel that energy yeah they did that
that that was a great one because again
for the people the initial fear was oh
it's just going to be we're in the
theater and that's it but there was
things behind the scenes you guys didn't
see where people came out the executive
leadership booty came out they talked
about you know the pipeline stuff they
learning from you know what I'm saying
the the red Force situation I was
surprised that kind of came up in a way
you know Sarah Bond comes out she talks
about the strides and where they're
making an improving you know what I'm
saying as far as you know Japanese games
and things of that nature you know
greeny with the community getting them
hype pump getting everybody pumps
obviously hold the line and all that
stuff but to see the excitement it was
an energy right that it's like it wasn't
none of this temper your expectation
type of energy it was yo we got
something Bing now right and we going to
hold y'all down for holding us down and
then Phil I got to give Phil credit to
dominant some credit he did something in
my opinion that was that was real man
talk in the sense that he's like look
I'm an emotional guy kind of wear my
heart on my sleeve sometimes and it was
like a indirect reference to the kind of
funny interview right he's like say
sometimes I may say things out of
emotion but it's kind of uh indicative
of what he talked about Pride which was
like I could see it but nothing's going
to matter until y'all see it right and
now that we see it and then they seeing
the blessing and the reception of it you
can see it's different but yeah to your
point being there in the building as
well as the FanFest to your point you
know they were it was it was a movie I
mean it was complete fan service and
then afterwards you know they had this
set up and and they were what's the word
like accessible you could yeah and you
could reach out to them like everyone's
there in them it's a celebrate you know
you know the celebration yeah you
remember remember the J that Matrix part
one got clowned and it was the um the
scene it was like a Zion moment
everybody's in z to this show like all
right so the only reason why I said that
right because um that was my perception
of it and this was this was always my
hope that they learn the Showmanship of
zenx and they incorporate the family
field of Xbox yeah and then translated
over to the show so we thought that last
year's show was the best pacing and this
year they continued that same pacing and
I and I respect it like the after shows
shout out to Paris and the teams um and
Microsoft uh proper show the proper show
I'm G get into what I didn't like yeah
let's go what I didn't like was y'all
guys don't understand what uh um the the
plus one the the and here's one more
thing don't understand what that means
all right it doesn't mean show me the
same knife that you had here and go it
was a big knife it was excited they you
know they had the Bazooka and Tuck they
was ready yeah yeah but you don't that's
not you don't show hayachi hat and go
and that's not that's not the plus one
okay that's that's just not it you
failed miserably when it came to that we
already knew Starfield was going to be
there so it wasn't a ah and we got one
more thing that was we knew what was
don't do that again all right so let me
back you what about Starfield having a
clip in the joint would you also oh we
going to get to that too get that ball
let me get your ball it's it's just I'm
start with where you was wrong oh okay
okay you could have and and don't do
that Clockwork thing there because I'll
explain as as as well show
us the
distance show us the Hail Mary the down
the block all right show us something
that you have't Tu that is Clockwork
known no don't do Clockwork there
because Clockwork was need where it was
at he they started getting a low no no
don't do the Clockwork there damn
disrespect do something else you could
have show something else I don't care
what it was damn but the hell Mary that
was there okay um the other the other uh
stub toe okay was
Forza um I
personally wanted to
see that killer and what I got
was yeah we Forza we here um we know
what we
do um that wasn't it like wow I I want
to because I'm I'm used to turn 10
showing up being turn 10 you and I know
I know when the game comes out this is
what happens when you have separate
little cons and stuff like that and for
is so big that they save a lot of that
stuff for their forer special events
okay and yeah that that kind of took
away from this because I wanted this to
show I want remember the first time we
saw F and we saw the raid Trac and they
was walking was doing all the stuff and
people was walking around show me that
okay show me that so and then you had
the um the hellblade yeah Didn't Have
gameplay now let me tell you I mean
didn't have fighting Combat gameplay
that these guys wanted the first time we
saw it I don't think that was run on an
Xbox series X okay yeah I think that was
run on a devkit or PC okay this one was
on a series they made it very clear yes
right and I think that's we're we're
confusing what we want and what they are
are showing the first one wasn't really
all that real it was real but it wasn't
really all that real this one is
representative of exactly what you're
going to get okay so here here we GNA
throw that in there and they're G to
make they and in the back they like yeah
it we said series X they going love it
but we thought that's what it looked
like over here the first time right you
know I'm saying so we know that over
here with some type of slight of hand
here you showing the actual hand we we
thought it was actual hand the first
time I understand where we at with it
next time we see it we'll see game uh
the combat we'll see all of that I I
believe that but that's the stubbor of
the toe okay um pacing of the show you
had to show your games of service that
was great you did all of that you had to
show everything that was going inside
Game Pass you had to show your your
third party deals that was there that
was great the pacing of the show was
fantastic um uh and the hardware oh yeah
the hardware was brief it was it was to
the point and it was there some idiot
online said Microsoft if you was able to
sell the the series X with one terabyte
at the same price releasing it now the
the the ssds didn't cost that price
before so now that they able to they
they they lower the cost on ssds you're
able to put a one ter in there now and
we could sell it for the same price that
we sell it before that's that's how
business works trust me if they was able
to put one terabite in back then and not
get beat all around the legs because the
the series s had the smaller um SSD size
and wasn't able to have as much stuff in
there they would they would have never
took that L then so just didn't make any
sense but the hardware yes little man we
know now is the money maker for them the
series X like Phil came out and said the
pipeline is opened up so you start
seeing more series x's in the store and
it it'll be uh easier for you to
purchase uh what because the reason why
I was so high on Forza because that was
my game that I really wanted to see the
most I feel you but let me can I push
back a little bit in the sense that
you're right historically Forza has
gotten no segments right where it's the
Deep dive you see the power you see why
they one of the kings of racing and you
know this the main line Motorsport right
the the graphical showcase what about
cuz I'm seeing the energy that people
are like yo we happy this the first Xbox
show with a future is so bright with the
other Studios with the 2018 draft class
right and now we ain't even got to rely
on the Big Mac large fries in the shake
of Halo gears what about that new day
energy I just wanted to
know okay is is it everything that I'm
hearing is it game of service game now
where we going to be having seasons and
all this real stuff like that's what I
wanted to know right um how how are you
going to because you know fors of
horizon is great and all that stuff but
there there's a distinct facts
separation between the two uh racing
titles right you know you have the
hardcore gritty dudes like um my my
cousin-in-law Oliver who he's he put
monitors together he got like three four
monitors and he has a steering wheel he
does that he's asking me about it and I
was like they really didn't say anything
new and and I was able to talk to him
about it a little bit but um that's what
I wanted and then uh the bigger titles
for me let's go what was the ones you
excited about um 33 Immortals yes I said
wow like the cloud is really out here
now mm right because now you're using to
offload uh uh bandwidth and stuff like
that this this stuff is really going to
hit different when we get a chance to
play it a vow I I didn't want a vow to
be uh a size of Skyrim or all that stuff
I I really wanted to be like a outer
worlds uh something tight something you
know just just a real good RPG with
branch and stories and but told in a
kingsfield manner I I want kingsfield
modern day and that's what showed me I
saw people talking about was a downgrade
in graphics no this is what you saw was
a CGI trailer before and now you saw a
actual game uh graphic so how can you
downgrade from a CGI it's just idiotic
stuff for people to to to nitpick I gave
this the show a 9.5 I think I've argued
about a vow too many times I'm gonna let
that
slip you gonna let it go
yeah are you on the side of it or you
disppointed just real quick I just need
to know I need know I'm not on the side
of a
downgrade I'm on the side that I feel
like they didn't properly keep our
expectations in check from the CGI they
showed us the first time okay so you
part because when you see when you see
the CGI from the first trailer it kind
of seemed more you know more of a
serious tone art style right but then
when you see that it does look a little
bit more like that colorful that that uh
that the outer worlds doing and and even
with that even with my disappointment to
a degree with that I still think this
game going to be if far as like review
Wise It's still goingon to get like an
80 89 990 91 92 it's still going to do
extremely well but I personally had a
different tone of art that I thought AOW
was going to look like and then when I
saw the game it didn't meet the
expectations they set when they showed
me that first trailer interesting okay
so it's
just everything that they showed I'm
super excited for a vow Theos 33 and the
Capcom game uh Capcom came out of the
blue I didn't expect it um it's
something that I definitely can't wait
to play and then you know of course
there's Starfield yeah we G get to that
but um those are the games that I'm
looking for the most the show was a
fantastic pacing I thought Microsoft hit
it out the part
I and I just like the fact that they
respected us as a Gaming Community yes
uh it's sometimes we laugh and we joke
and there a console war crap and you
know hold line or whatever the hell um
and I know that everybody says you know
we bootlick um
corporations I hear you dudes right and
I and I hear everything that you guys
are saying and I know you're going to
say well they they don't owe us anything
they just need to make good games and I
just support good games shut up
shut up you don't want anybody that you
hand your money over they smack you in
the face with a good game wow man take
your game and get her out of here oh
they smacked me but they gave me a good
game stop that right um you want to have
some respect some Rapport going through
and I know you probably saying that
Microsoft is doing this because they're
in third place let's see what happens
when they in first place that will be
happening
soon very soon right very very soon so
much that you can see it I can see it we
both know it I honestly believe with
this level of management that's in place
and I'm seeing it from the top down to
the
bottom they will operate the same way
when they're in first
place and it will be the same report
that you do have so I'm just happy that
gaming as a whole Microsoft did exactly
what I hope they did save gaming that
week okay no fair enough fair enough y
pretty much knocked out all the points I
wanted to say so as far as my feelings
is just that like you said the um I just
feel like the the energy from um
executive leadership the the way they
presented was tremendous I think they've
really solved the problem as far as you
know showcase presentation pacing game
to game to game they didn't do the
couches on that joint you know what I'm
saying that was for extended they they
they've got their pocket and I also the
direct I feel you know gave that more
indepth you know path to really
showcasing which we'll get into um as
far as the games obviously Fable for me
was mind-blowing if playground pulls
this off the the level of production
value the gra the graphical Fidelity is
so good it has people question it and
that that is something to really to
really come in you know I thought that
was phenomenal I thought inxile look
inxile we've been told we told people
for a long time they've been sleeping
they cooking boy and you know that is a
super talented team that is the the
creators of Fallout that is you know
Wasteland 3 one of the greatest turnbas
games going storyline diver like they
are so ambitious I love your man who's
too bougie Lord crawlin and he got the
he got the thing where
you the peasants he will not walk
amongst the common folk and he he's not
touching that that peasant ground yo
when I saw that I said y this is so
called it felt so Silver
Surfer he yes my feet will not be
touching the ground but you know the
ambitious of the time travel that that
was amazing you know I agree with
everybody want to vow you know to
see obliv obsidian stay in their pocket
and say we are not trying to cop we're
going to do what we do best I do push
back on attic with the um tone thing I
think this is my feeling they still
showed dark biomes they was still dark
things so I think that they're just
showing a diversity in biomes I saw a
desert area I didn't look at it now if
they would have came out and he's
slashing clowns and it's he and then I'm
like okay it's colorful it's a different
tone I saw magic to the level let's be
real and I'm an Elder Scrolls Star Wars
guy I mean star Starfield kind of guy
but like we got to be clear with when
you play Oblivion and Sky you shoot the
magic and it's pure and it's just this
single little like they're doing
singularities like Mass Effect with the
with the enemies floating in the air you
controlling the thing then they got the
the standard you know they got the
double barrel they got the sword and
shield yeah cuz dud came with the knife
and the
shield they got it reminded me of um
damn Mass Effect with like um like
biotics the biotic elevated somebody
elev yeah and you doing this on next gen
Tech with all these characters floating
the air controlling that then they had
the boot a sparter this is sparter kick
to the Joint you beheading people like
come on like I I get it people may you
know just wanted to have this one type
of biome and all is going to be down in
the dungeons with the skeleton enemies I
get that but yeah like bro like to me it
was still showing that energy in
addition to other Lush areas I have no
problem with it so that's just me but
again I'm biased I love the city and
they've been holding it down and as far
as I'm concerned they've had Xbox on
their back during the series console
generation no one can take you can say
what you want cuz I even I was a hater a
skeptic of grounded in the beginning and
P but when you play them games they are
quality games so salute to them 33
Immortals I agree s I'm with you on the
atlas I'm showing the um you know the
IPS the Persona tactics Jo I thought
that looked cool um you know what no
one's talking about lowkey I know I
probably going to pop it in and then
uninstall it because the hard drive
space Microsoft Flight the rescue thing
they had fire rescue ambulance this like
it had so many is a new game right yeah
it well it has so many modes I'm like
that's kind of interesting like I ain't
going to front like and it's a Soo is a
like they've show now you see what they
could do they almost get I want to do
the Doom yeah the Doom joint was kind of
crazy and they have something like that
was like combat almost like like dog
fighting no you you saw the um the the
aial is
uh aiel joint so I me salute to them for
the support like King said live service
they going to still support see the look
they have to Monkey Island is a big deal
that's a big deal that's a big deal now
Fallout 76 but but according to you know
what even even Fallout
76 come on don't let's not lie people
when they told us to buy the joint and
they a't tell us anything they because
they have they have no service to throw
it in we highly skeptical in what Todd
was asking and then it came in the state
that it did but for it to be inside Game
Pass yeah of course and for them to say
yo throwing stuff in there we going to
keep fixing it yeah it it it works yeah
for that Community they're getting
content for that for that he said for
those guys look for them you know I
personally want a Fallout New Vegas
remake or Fallout 4 that's just me you
know what I'm saying but U oh yeah shout
out to Don n we disrespect to T we gonna
get that was that that was really cool I
like the climbing little indie game the
attic like I forgot the name of it you
talking about the um the one that yeah
yo stop it you doing that and then I'm
just saying that game of the year but
Sol is Right yo path of the Goddess
where he got this Shing thing he's
protected little Thea did you see did
you see the W Chong going and and and
the chall five martial arts
sensibilities and Y that for a new IP
big deal anyway let's get to the main
event because you know what we here and
I want to U respect um Alex Tom I got to
get his bars on this too um let's get to
this direct real quick with uh with
Starfield you know um I'm going to just
jump
off you know we got we got to we got to
really be respectful you know o of God
Howard here you know he got a lot of
arrows slung at him you know the bug
desda we talked about listen think about
the pressure they have had coming into
this game yep where this game has to
save Xbox this game if it's not this
Xbox is out of here um just so much you
know and then obviously 76 which is
Bethesda Austin right a separate team
but they still carry in the slings of
that but what it goes to show me you
know even with the red Force situ all
that stuff that's not them for them to
show out the way they did under this
amount of pressure and not only meet
expectation exceed expectation to the
point I'mma keep it a buck me and R I
think talk about this you can make the
argument this is the greatest Showcase
of a game in gaming conference history
you can make the AR like you can't walk
away from this and say I don't know what
Starfield is remember that talk dudes
are capping they don't even know what
Starfield is right now the only thing
you can tell me is you like Cog I don't
like them Western RPGs I don't do that
kind of game fine if you say that fine I
ain't going to push back but if you
going to walk away and tell me one to
one what game is doing exactly this I
challenge there is none there is none
the scope is insane so it's like this
was really a Shining Moment for that
team you know I got a chance to talk to
Todd and Pete pre-show and the energy
was kind of like yo we just hope we you
know we're getting excited you know we
hope you guys like what we have to offer
but I'm going tell you king talking to
them after and seeing how it was
received
and people Blown Away with the
possibilities that they can
do they were literally like it was like
proud dad like y we are so happy Andy yo
you know P telling me all the things you
can do about boarding people ship and
and raiding stuff and doing stuff all
the things that the algorithm created
inine and here's the other thing I want
to do because I do see this disingenuous
you know we G to get to the frames talk
I'm not going avoid that right and yes
Cog would love it to be 60 and yes I was
disappointed initi when we heard the 30
right I'm not going to say I'm not you
know of course we going to want that but
here's the thing and this is where a lot
of people with these disingenuous oh
well because Horizon is 60 frames per
second and oh because this is 60 fra bro
that's not even the same Stratosphere
when you play a game where you kill
someone and they bodies remain there
when you play a game and everything in
the game is interactable and I'm I'm got
to call I love Final Fantasy but let's
be clear adct you know when you play
Final Fantasy the remakes or whatever
whatever the game puts a Shining Light
on the only interactable thing you can
touch in the world you can't go in every
house you can't kill every NPC you can't
do anything those are static because
they're sacrificing the gameplay and the
complexity of the systems for the
graphical Fidelity that is a game design
choice that is so for people to sit
there down you want to say hey these
models ain't looking as sharp as
whatever okay fine but name the game
that's doing what they're doing the
things that stood out for me like I said
the melee combat was crazy running down
on dudes punching them doing all that
type of stuff you know I felt like the
the skill tree system was at the
procedure generation we know about the
Gunplay much improved you know what I'm
saying the jetpacking moving around way
way improved you know it it became a
point it was like what can't this game
do like what literally like what can you
can play it how you truly want to play
it so I think the issue comes down to
yes you as far as the you can be
disappointed that you're not 60 but if
if it comes down to limiting the scope
of this game so that you can't interact
with everything for the 60 I ain't going
to lie like there's a PC for you to take
it to where you want to take it to but
I'm on the side of innovation and doing
things I've never seen before in gaming
so in that respect this is where tears
of the kingdom does come in in that
respect gaml K here's the last part I
know I'm going
along what's funny about Twitter and
social media it is truly an echo chamber
because you know why for the people who
are like this is an embarrassment and
fair you want to say Xbox touted power
fair right and and this is this okay
fair do you see what these pre-orders
are doing do you see what the Zeitgeist
is doing it's the same like how tears of
the kingdom was people I know people who
are the most detractors of Starfield
said yo I ain't even going to hold
you I ain't even going to hold I got
shout out to the LSM Community you know
what I'm saying S sim and the crew I got
people who were like yo I'm literally
buying an Xbox for this game like of
course they got to execute and all that
stuff but I'm finished blow V8 I had to
get cuz my thing was I heard a lot of
talk you know and and not respecting God
Howard's name as if he don't got his
face his games ain't on Mount Rushmore
and as if morwin Skyrim Oblivion Fallout
are not on Mount rushall are that games
of the gener we're not doing that so for
people who had that yo respect this is
the track record that we respecting and
now you'reall getting to see a glimpse
of of course they got to execute of
course we got to make sure it's not
technically broken but we are not going
to disrespect Legends in the game for
some Fanboy foolishness we not doing
that and it's beautiful to see them reap
the rewards and the reception of what
this game is attempting to do okay I'm
done I got my random I had to get that
off I'm sorry I been holding that cuz
don't let don't let this game be no 90
something I will be messy and I remember
all the tweets and all the comments I'm
coming for all of y'all cuz y'all was
talking we're Reckless to Legends in the
game period we're going to respect our
Legends that's the last thing I'm going
say okay now I'm finished
sorry anyone wants to jump
in I I mean I thought adct was going to
get I was in my feelings I was in my
feelings I apologize sorry uh here
here's how I feel about it I'm going
play it on PC um you know I I'll have
access to both so you know I'll jump in
and out to see if it's even playable on
the Xbox uh I don't even think it's just
the Starfield that's the issue it's the
fact that we were pretty much kind of
like sold a console that you know 60
frames is going to be the standard 120
is going to be the is going to be the
exceptions or and and back to back to
the AAA products they're have are coming
out 30 frames you know I can I don't
think it would be as bad people would
still complain but it's the fact that
redfall and Starfield were both 30
frames that is what's making it look
spooky and it's like when you come out
there and you make ultimate decisions
like that Aaron people are going to
check you later when it's St when games
start
missing the the Target and that that's
pretty much as far as that goes I I will
be playing Starfield on PC andx box just
depending on what's going on at the time
uh but for the people that's genuinely
upset because it doesn't run 60 I feel
you for the people that's just using it
to get some traction to their
Channel go somewhere else with
that what about the game itself sir oh I
mean the g games games fire you here's
the thing I've always said from the
start you know you can argue that Final
Fantasy not Final Fantasy you can argue
AR that Todd Howard and
Bethesda together have a better track
record than Naughty Dog uh so you
know I mean it's the truth like but
here's the thing here's the thing
naughty dog has made defining games they
they they've C catapulted a lot of
things
forward but thda pretty much catapulted
the RPG genre every time they've made a
game two or three times
sure you you could you could give them
Fallout 76 even though they didn't make
that game it was a sister Studio that
made that game you can make that
argument and you know Bethesda will get
that smoke just because Bethesda got
that smoke because their name is on the
on the box but Skyrim sold like what 80
million units still selling Skyrim to
this day so crazy Oblivion morn Fallout
3 they didn't make Fallout New Vegas
even Fallout 4 which is in my opinion
the worst Fallout out of the Bethesda
type of
games still yeah was almost Game of the
Year facts it was a a nomination for
Game of the Year and people want to sit
there and they look at Fallout 4 and
they look at as a negative notation even
though I feel like it's the worst
Fallout they still like 86 that was the
consider the three yeah was so it's like
look fall Fallout four I do feel like
was that shren downwards and and 76
didn't help help the the matter
but we can't deny what they've done in
the
past Bethesda has made some of the most
beloved games in gaming history
soundtrack to the streets period period
say morwin organic growth by the way
when it comes to
Starfield it just can they can they
deliver what they say you know fair for
all we know they just they could have
just showed us the the the highlight the
game and then we play it a lot of the
systems don't work the way they
demonstrate it but it works not the way
it works that's fair at the end of the
day I do feel like Xbox has show that
you can get Faith in it but it's one of
those things where I always say trust
and verify don't just trust no doubt
fair enough fair enough fair enough no
doubt no doubt um s you know now it's
got a chance to marinate I I haven't
really talked to you too much about it
you know Starfield where where you at
with this directed Starfield um we I was
impressed I was very very impressed and
again for me my thoughts going in is
like I just worried what I worried about
is that you know Todd's ambition and
trying to make this vast world would
sort of
leave the stuff that I want to see more
more depth and like character and story
and like more density in in in in in
cities and things like that I was like
well if he's going for that something's
going to suffer and that's going to be
it so I was worried about that now I'm
watching this and just this entire
breakdown of what this game finally is
he's basically telling you this game is
the culmination of everything that we've
ever tried to implement in the Bethesda
game we're going to put into this game
right and it's probably going to be the
most polished version of all of those
implementations and it's going to be in
this game so in a lot of ways to this
point this is the magnumopus This is
Everything that we've learned everything
that we've implemented everything that
we've heard you when it comes to what
the fans want we're going to try to put
into this game and what better game to
try to do that with than a vast space
adventure when you're essentially trying
to to to create space um and I think
everything they talked about here just
kind of It kind of blew me away the
ambition right I'm still a little bit
you know and I say worried in quotations
I'm still a little bit worried about the
procedural generated Stu Stu and and and
how it's because for me I'm an idiot I I
know full well I should not be playing
these games this way because I don't
have the time to right like I should be
the dude that goes in and goes from
Story Mission to Story Mission Story
Mission spend I should be that I should
be the dude that's like oh yo 30 hours
whatever the main campaign is do that
and be done with it no the first thing I
do is okay where am I supposed to go no
I'm going the other direction squirrel
what's that in the distance what's that
right so I know I'm going to encoun that
other procedural generated stuff that
may not be you know they not have the
the depth that the other stuff has so my
thing is just that it doesn't feel
repetitive and syy like if you go to a
planet or something like that that
there's only a couple of things to do
that it's something new it's a story
thing or whatever the case may be like I
just want that I was GNA say when it
comes to like the procedure generated
stuff let's be real here if they only
had like six seven planets because it's
Story related and nothing else was there
people say that game doesn't feel like
you're you're the universe like you're
traveling like as long as like the core
gamep play is is isn't procedurally
generated like when it comes to like the
bigger cities because I don't think they
will be some of the planets that's
direct Story related and then when it
comes to like getting your resources
maybe uh farming certain things that
stuff is simulated I don't think people
are gonna have an issue with that I
think people are reading too much into
that yeah again but it is something that
again when you think about the thing the
aspects of the game that are going to be
created story-wise the the the sort of
the cities that are supposed to be super
dense and populated and have all this
stuff you know if you see something that
doesn't have that level of detail in it
it'll be a little bit disappointing but
again you got to take that in context
when you think about the scope of the
entire game so I was super like really
really really impressed um and they they
went all out you know with the with the
special editions with the with the head
set the the controller so they they're
doing for this game what they're
supposed to to get the word out there
and again the proofers in the pudding
when it comes to yeah you can wait for
it in Game Pass there's a lot of people
that aren't waiting for it in Game Pass
I bet to be quick yeah yeah I was it was
funny I was talking I was talking to
addict that I talked to Cog yesterday
because I was like yo y'all know that
the Early Access for this game starts
when we're in we we'll be in Washington
Working shout out to
gay being locally download look at this
guy shout out to the RO
Ally that K that King will be having sh
yeah yeah so this is the thing I was
like damn yo I know yall GNA be want to
sitting there Blaze and we G to have to
be work in the show floor shout out to
the series ass that can go into hotel
rooms
very very easily very EAS but shout out
to us being at work yeah yeah fact
exactly we be too tired to do anything
yo we GNA stop acting like we we finish
these shows and we get back to
the
game we got to do to eat and go to sleep
we got a new plan shout out shout out to
luck we got a new plan maybe things will
be a little I don't think so all right
we'll see we'll see I know how my legs
feel after the show shout out the little
man who will make the trip with the L
yeah might be little black man yeah yo
hey yo hey shout out to mic getting mad
first with the black and
white I got a little white man we not
doing that we not doing
that we not doing racial connotations on
series as
CLE I
can't not doing that little bit I can't
they should have did that they should
have had him on the
piano yo you stupid need me for
marketing baby you need to get kick d
the marketing bag for real for real he's
moving
out that yeah for real I was I was
impressed I'm excited more in Alpha the
game than I have been um because again
we finally got the explanation of what
it is yes and what it is it really is is
saying hey everything that I've learned
from working on these games for God
knows how long I'm going to try to
implement into this game and try to give
you the most vast and still detailed
experience possible while giving you the
freedom to just do what you want to do
like I I can't imagine how many penis
spaceships we're going to
see it's gon to happen
Gundams youin invading my [__] pulling
up to me with the
phace but but that's the crazy thing
right all of that stuff could be in
there and then when you think about you
know creation engine and the mods and
and stuff like that and and where that's
going to go and then they're already
talking about you know additional
content and DLC
so it is it is a bgs Studios release in
every way shape and form it is it is
bubbling up to that oh this is one of
those and this is a moment in time um
and I and I'm excited oh why he said yo
the black one got the bigger SSD
yo yo M the two of piggy time well done
well done well done wow
wow yall really doing this leave that
alone y got to leave these these
stereotypes alone y'all got to stop y
got to
stop well done I like that I might have
to get a new little
logo oh man continue black man no
continue s we are not doing that
continue so I'm I'm excited cuz this is
one of those that's going to be it's
going to be a it's going to be a moment
and it's hard to get moments like that
anymore man I mean we don't have we
don't have like midnight releases and
things like that anymore like that that
doesn't happen as much so the the
moments in time like this are are
different right they're not the same as
they used to be so yeah but they they
did it man they did it what else did he
derail in the show I'm looking at the
chat chill Xbox believes in diverse
expansive package
Super Chat Robert Kell good well done y
ridiculous manid State can't take y
seriously in a ro at all we can't have a
serious conversation in the realm ever
hard drive the bbhd
oh this is what's happening it's you
it's going down K get your balls up and
then I do want cuz I got to leave I want
to get his final fantasy topic before he
leaves so let's get your balls off a
Starfield cuz you you the person I felt
the hardest to please I want to know
what um what was your stand out listen
uh I I I'm happy for
Todd Todd ready the game where came out
last year and it would it came out to a
chorus of criticism mixed with
agulation and I think now most of the
criticism will you know get smaller with
Wayne Uh from the extra polish there's
no one that can say that they can
compare both
presentations and don't see this time
has benefited
Todd graphically and and you know let's
just move away from the 30 frames yeah
versus 60 frames um graphically this
game took a a bump up yes yes um and it
I don't see certain things that I was
seeing before I went back and watched
the other one and then I'm watching this
I'm like okay this is truly a benefit to
him and I think if this is your seminal
this is your Apex this is your
climax um to say he is stamping his name
now before he was hoping that his games
would be a game of the year before he
was uh in the running for making a game
that can be uh a pillar and and has the
standard test of time I think this is
the game that he tells you it's G to be
Game of the Year this is uh a genre
bending uh uh game this is a game that
would stand the test of time I think he
knows what he's capable of and I think
this is the time that he steps into that
jacket I think before he was wearing the
jacket as like a show something I think
this
time he is the jacket like he he is God
Howard like we give him that name from
his previous accomplishments I think
he's showing you now why he's God Howard
could be and this is it right now and
the game looks great I'm going to sit
down I'm going to delve into it I'm
still on uh
what I can
do forward
[Music]
March what is he doing is he
doing he about to be twoo extra this is
extra about to get demonetized we about
to get demonetized we're
done line down the line
shot
[Music]
we're about to get copyright strike
we're done no we're
not to hold down the
line all you
jellyfish that
ran this is your weapon woo I am my
weapon this is my armor this is my
shield oh and I will never yield not one
time did I think this deal would get
blocked and I told you maggots to stand
in line and stand next to me now this is
the day that I have promised you I told
you if you stand all you will receive
the promised land and we are here those
that ran in
fear not here I want you to look over
and I want you to see that brother right
next to you that sister right next to
you that held the line with you you had
all the ups and all the downs but you
did not Bend break or fold you are made
of Sterner stuff the stuff that Legends
are made of we have individuals here
that are frauds those guys ran and we
know who you are and trying to come back
wait a
second wait a
second have a new
fold what is that the FTC have
folded the CMA is on the
run and the main protagonist has signed
the
deal yes
we have them right where we want them
beneath the
boot and we will not let up we will
continue to press we will push this line
so far down they throat they will choke
the line for months and weeks do not
give in do not fold do not break we
understand now Phil Dominus Maximus
Spencer is the closer and he closed this
deal
you stood tall today your day now with
all those badges that we gave out we
them proud cuz you earned them I do not
want to see anybody false flagging out
there that did not they would to
celebrate they was scared B off you
mag but it was looking spooky
K can we F them for not having the
confidence and and you giving the the
the community inspiring the community
you must reapply and and you must have a
maid man or maid woman Fout for
you now go get your Xbox series X and S
and get right back in line Soldier and
if you don't have this you don't have
[Laughter]
is wow there you guys have it uh it is
officially over ended up being almost 5
hours long I decided to cut some of the
later end stuff of the year like the
past couple months because I felt like
that was pretty recent I didn't want you
guys going over content that you just
recently watched uh this is mainly
attracting you know people that came
into US during the year you know those
podcasts like the Video Game Awards uh
that stuff is pretty relatively fast and
relatively soon and I had to end it with
the King right man I had it with the
King right once again appreciate you all
for coming through until next time we're
out
peace